going I think we have some experiments
to go
seems that everything that I do that
seems like like it would improve the
model just breaks it
more I did think of one thing though
that I
hadn't accounted
for I think we'll do that for a bit and
then when Captain's on we'll uh continue
code
cool because I might end up having to do
a little bit of math on this
I actually might have somebody that
wants to chat right now so I might have
to delay stream for a second we'll
let's just do this for a little bit I I
have some messages I'm responding to on
the side but um let me get re Cream open
and I'll talk a little bit about what I
have planned here
okay this is going to
be just some followup work on the
algorithm I've been developing
I've had at least some
ideas since
um well I've had at least some ideas
since the uh the last time
here what I'd like to
do first thing and this is the remote
box so we'll get ourselves a new term
okay we're going to comment out
this learned
layer and we're going to use a fixed
learnable but fixed set of parameters
here and then we will do the same
here first thing I want to do is see if
this does anything at all on its own
wait I did I only make the change on uh
I think I did only make the change
here I did only make the change here so
let me go fix that
let's see if this learns anything
initially
it's immediately better than the
uh the other version at
least then the next plan here is going
to
be is going to be this
subtract the reward standard deviation
from gamma like
this this will be the next
plan I suppose we can talk
about some of the improvements that I uh
I came up with while I'm
here so here's the je paper
right and one of the big things I
realized right
is draw on
line I almost want to have a tablet for
when I need it here
but so the way that gamma Works in our
implementation this is
rstd which is the standard deviation of
the uh empirical
reward this is one this is like 0 2 or
whatever so our curve looks like
this and then generalized Advantage
estimation uh looks more like this
right so they go down to zero whereas we
cap out here so this is scaled wrong and
the thing that I realized right that I
thought I was doing weirdly
before oh does that solve the n
wait is that actually work hold
on does that solve the
end
um
true there's no way it was that simple
right
all we're going to let's run that
experiment on this box before we forget
here head's a little fuzzy right now for
explaining
algorithms let me at least get these
experiments set up and run a couple
things locally and then I'll try to
actually go through this
formally oops we want this
page this page this
page lovely super maven's
great I need to
do comment
these these no longer exist in the new
algorithm
soon as this runs we'll uh we'll try
some stuff
locally then we'll go from there
hey
Spencer we're making good progress on
this algorithm now apparently just went
from completely broken to it looks like
it's
working you check out this commit I made
to fix roll
out uh yeah because the death Branch I
did some screwy stuff in
e3b where's PR wait this is not a PR
this is a commit to your
branch you can you can PR it if you want
um not a huge deal I if it's in Dev yeah
Dev should kind of not break
horribly um but yeah I've kind of just
been going fast and loose on that Branch
lately with all the algorithm Dev I've
been going absolutely insane trying to
fix uh fix this
thing let how's the uh the GPU Drive
agent
going was that oh was that fine though
okay I didn't even check I just assumed
I did something stupid let me look
why do you use the forward train
function
again new
forward yeah this wasn't e3b this was
separate optimizations
e3b agent calls yeah it's fine you can
do this either way um lstm cell and lstm
are the same lstm cell is just faster
it's faster for like single step like
this yeah this looks like you did um
this looks like you match the API is
fine it had no
State well let me know if you're getting
results that look like it's getting a
good score but the models don't look
good if that happens then there's
probably a bug and if not it's
fine yeah this particular change is
really obnoxious but the thing is it was
30%
perf so it was worth it
literally 30% per looks fine then it's
fine don't need to
overthink I'm only like really really
picky with with stuff like that if it's
uh if it's going to main or like
something that people are actually
using I'm allowed to break
Dev Dev is my playground for building
new RL stuff
also we have the e3b one of the uh the
e3b
authors uh in the puffer Discord which
is kind of
cool I would like it if the algorithm
worked maybe they know how to get it to
work maybe I just did something stupid I
don't know
so this immediately breaks training
right
here no it still runs it just takes
longer GPU Drive got a visual not
learning for agents all agents yet two
agents get there and use rewards so I'm
making some
changes it's doing donuts on the
goal yeah that's what happens when you
give it a continuous
that has to do with how you handle end
of episode
bounce but yeah you can just have it
give it a reward for getting to the goal
whatever it'll train so fast it won't
matter it's a 91 step problem that's
literally nothing
log score is always
saying log of
score always saying one well are you
only logging when it gets to the
goal hey
Brad are you logging zero when it fails
to reach the
goal that's usually the culprit
set to
zero yeah but you
don't the Aggregate and log thing right
you you have like a log thing per agent
and then you put it into this big like
stack of logs whenever an agent finishes
an
episode so when it if it fails to reach
the goal in 90 steps or whatever it is
um you still have to log and you log it
is zero I think you're only logging
success trajectories that's usually why
that bug happens
this this is not how I had it originally
right maybe it
is running 1.6 mil
erratically how did you achieve such
faster training speeds with what with RL
what were the main changes you made
compared to traditional RL
pipelines um one the base M itself has
to be fast enough to keep up right if
your m is slow you can't train faster
than you can get data so we wrote a
bunch of M's and C they're really fast
we use them for uh our
baselines uh two your whole
vectorization in a wrapper stack has to
be way way way faster than existing uh
people basically just didn't even try in
this area we do really nice shared
memory stuff so that you can immediately
get all your data onto the main thread
and we also do asynchronous simulation
that can cause you to spend 0% time in
the end uh if you enable
that uh and then three is we use a a
much larger batch size for training
we're not going to train on like eight
agents or something it's going to always
be uh at least 256 but usually closer to
a th000 2,000 4,000 something like that
with batch sizes in the low hundreds of
thousands
typically uh and then from there there's
a whole different set of considerations
for optimization right because now
everything is running so fast things
that you didn't have to worry about
optimizing before you really have to
optimize so we have our own trainer uh
that we've just like done a whole bunch
of profiling on and overtime has gotten
faster and faster and now I mean this
800k is on the low end here frankly we
can get up to 2.5 million on the same
environment with the same architecture
how's algo
land I mean it's irritating but it's
going you know I think what I want to do
is I want to I want to temporarily
introduce a hyper parameter
here I think I want to just temporarily
Rd but yeah it's been a lot of work um I
will say it's like it's pretty
consistent work like the approach we
have will consistently just keep making
RL faster and better so that's
nice though I am now having to do
um I having to start doing a little bit
more algorithm side
work because we're getting to the point
where I'm finding all the skeletons in
the closet with uh the last decade of
RL and we just really need to fix
and then I will go over the
algorithm experiments we have running
and
I don't know I just needed like lurp
parameter so I just called it puff
whatever we're not going to keep this in
the final algorithm because we're not
adding more Viper parameters to the
final algorithm but I want to see what
difference it makes for sensitivity
analysis purposes all right let me
commit all this up let me run this
experiment on uh the other box and then
we'll go from there
and let me go figure because I actually
I forgot what boxes I
have I have one other box that I reserve
for my own purposes even if I don't use
it 24/7 just so that I have it when I
need
okay box four I believe is
mine do I have wait what do I what box
was I using is it
four make sure I don't kill anybody's
jobs
good I got to redo this container don't
I
container GRE an hour awesome that's uh
that's perfect cuz I'm just going to
finish up this stuff on this algorithm
do a couple little things here and then
I'll be free for that as
oh it's just a permissioning [ __ ]
thing Marathon stream was surprised to
see 10 hours on
YouTube it wasn't even that much of a
marathon stream I didn't even come back
after dinner
I try to maintain like 70 plus hour work
weeks it's hard it's not even like a
crazy number of hours to work at all is
the thing I've done way worse it's
just with stuff like this I get burnt
out so lot of thinking on
stuff though frankly I think being bored
Burns me out way way quicker than having
to like think really
I just need to get these experiments
running and then I'll go through what uh
what I've been working on with the new
this is so
stupid well
that
whatever
still could someone please explain why
this is
like this
H the reason I'm just pasting these
random
commands Without Really checking is if
it breaks the OS I'm just going to go
out there and reinstall it without
freaking
lvm because this is obnoxious
it's kind of like 10 minutes to install
and get puffer working on a new uh
machine at this
point all right so hopefully that works
um over the next like 10ish minutes I'm
going to have to build three containers
in order to get this experiment running
so what I'm going to do that'll be
interesting during that time I'll talk a
little bit about the algorithm and
things that I've
tried and I'll just leave this up here
so that I can monitor it and you know
whenever it builds a layer I'll have to
go back to
it
okay so there are two references that we
need for this
algorithm the first is the generalized
Advantage estimation paper the second is
a blank pad to draw some
stuff
um so what is this and why is this so
important generalized Advantage
estimation and I'm going to give this in
a in a way that I don't think has been
really
covered correctly before I'll give my
take on this so this was published in
2016 this paper has you know a bunch of
citations
but it's not po Poo's a year later also
John Schulman 24,000 citations arguably
the most important paper in
RL
okay but here's the thing
po it's this direct afterwards like this
direct next thing from
Schulman uh and it uses generalized
Advantage estimation in fact it really
only does two things total this
algorithm okay and one of them is this
clipping function which this looks
complicated this looks
complicated but then here this is this
is the version everyone actually uses
it's literally just you clip the weights
so that they don't change too much from
the previous weights that that is it
there is nothing remotely complicated
here um so there's this dead simple
change and really all this does is let
you train on stale data that's all this
does so the great Hallmark P algorithm
is just this line except that it also
uses generalized Advantage estimation
and really all of the stuff that makes
po work
over anything else uh is in this
generalized Advantage estimation paper
so arguably you know this is and
especially with how complex this method
is um this is arguably the more
important defining piece of Po you
cannot remove this from po without
completely breaking the algorithm uh in
many cases you can remove the other part
of Po without breaking the algorithm you
just have to have a a fast simulator and
not train on too much stale
data so really really really
important uh piece of RL architecture
here RL algorithms
here there's a whole bunch of
math but it simplifies down to
this this function and then they give
you these example special cases of well
this is equal to training to match
discounted reward if uh if Lambda equals
1 and then it is equal to this like
one-step bootstrap here if Lambda equals
z but otherwise it's this exponentially
weighted decaying sum that's kind of
fancy and
complicated let me build the next layer
and then we will continue
it's basically just eligibility
traces applied to Advantage function
which is itself very old if you know
some math here that I don't please let
me know because I don't I don't
understand where this comes from
particularly I just see that this is a
mixture of two
exponentially uh exponentially weighted
decaying some factors and really it
turns out that the gamma which is called
the discount Factor isn't even really
the discount Factor the discount factor
is actually gamma time
Lambda then you kind of have this extra
discount factor that is
gamma in the internals of the
function um or where is it yeah
here but
whatever so this is all PO is right it
is generalized Advantage estimation plus
clipping and all clipping does is allow
you to train on slightly off policy data
that's
it uh the thing is this is really
bad generalized Advantage estimation is
a really bad algorithm for us to be
depending on in like the core thing that
we use everywhere and PO is really good
like seriously lots of Deep Mind people
very smart math people who know way more
than me have tried very hard to come up
with all sorts of very fantasy well
theoretically grounded algorithms and po
kind of just
wins maybe soft actor critic and
Robotics but we still use poo there
sometimes too
okay uh so why is Je bad well GAE has
two hyper
parameters
gamma and
Lambda what do these hyper parameters
do these hyper parameters collectively
tell you how far ahead you care about
rewards it's telling you specifically
how to do credit
assignment why would that be a
problem
well this was a benchmark eligibility
Trace basic thing when Computing TD
error get the true value of v We either
take two extremes MC returns or TD which
has been shown to work great td0 does
not work great td0 gives
you uh very low variance but it that
does not train on its own from anything
that I've seen because it's like a
onstep bootstrap
function weighted min max yeah okay so
that is exactly what it is so then cool
they didn't come up with it from nothing
then it was just that I
guess so anyways why is let me put this
last build in and then we'll finish the
story at least the motivation of the
thing that I'm trying to
do
okay so this is the Prof gen Benchmark
it has a bunch of arcade games they were
pretty fast for the time you know
they're rendered this thing you can get
this up to like over a 100,000 steps per
second if you're
clever um and the idea of this Benchmark
was you're going to train whatever your
algorithm is you know you're going to
develop your algorithm using a bunch of
these environments and then you're going
to train you know you're going to just
take your algorithm exactly as it is out
of the box and you're going to throw it
on new environments that you haven't
seen before and you're going to see how
well your algorithm does at least this
is how it was done in one of the
competitions so you still train but
you're not like allowed to fiddle with
the new environments a whole bunch so
it's like a held out environment
right that doesn't
work why doesn't that
work well people didn't really figure
out why that didn't work for many years
in fact I
think I don't think many people still
understand this because it was a very
small detail and a very small blog post
and you had to make a couple
connections
oops here's a hyperparameter algorithm
paper from mbai they solve
proen but they solve proon by tuning
hyper parameters individually on each
end so they don't really obey the rules
of the initial one where you have to
solve everything with the same set of
hyper
parameters but if you actually look at
the data from
this gamma and Lambda vary dramatically
across environments and if you think
about that for about two seconds it's
pretty obvious why right if you have a
game like this one which is in a little
grid you only care about rewards a few
steps ahead but if you have like a
continuous
platformer you have to care about some
rewards that are many many many steps
ahead so gamma and Lambda telling you
the Horizon that you care about credit
assignment uh by definition prevents you
from applying this without retuning the
hyper parameters to multiple different
Ms completely screws over the robustness
of this algorithm on the base of hyper
parameters so yeah I I think pretty much
only the people who are around puffer
lib know this because this is something
that I kind of figured out based on the
in viw paper uh digging into some of
their
data so very
specific but it applies very broadly
because if you like think about it now
it makes sense that you can't use these
sets of hyper parameters like anywhere
without
retuning the fact that the vast majority
of Academia uses the Atari hyper
parameters is just because they haven't
bothered retuning them and on every
single environment in puffer Li that we
have done tuning uh when we get those
parameters right there's a massive Gap
in performance so massive of a gap in
fact that it dwarfs the difference that
any anybody is reporting with using
different algorithms so whatever fancy
algorithm that you came up with that
works 20% better doesn't matter tuning
the hyper parameters makes a difference
of
3x so that's pretty
big right that's pretty big because that
tells us two things one it tells us why
the vast majority of published RL
research is wrong and doesn't replicate
or doesn't transfer to other
environments you didn't tune hyper
parameters this is why you have to tune
hyper parameters this is why the default
hyper parameters are not going to be
good across a large variety of tasks
right uh and two it tells us we probably
should replace generalized Advantage
estimation with something that doesn't
have this
problem but that's kind of
hard right now people have been coming
up with new algorithms for the longest
time people that have you know are Deep
Mind art Google people who have way way
way more math experience than I do I'm
really not a great my math kind of sucks
I'm a pretty good engineer I'm a pretty
good scientist I'm a terrible
mathematician so how do I think I'm
going to be able to come up with an
algorithm uh that's better than this
well a few things first of all I have
this Insight here from having made this
connection with carbs with the
hyperparameter tuning work that we' uh
that we did with
puffer and with a few other results
right like is the story that I just told
you the second thing is that even though
we don't have Deep Mind resources we
don't have thousands of gpus we now have
environments that train at millions of
steps per second so we can run a lot of
experiments and very very quickly tell
whether we're right or wrong so even if
I get a lot of the algorithmic details
wrong several several times I can just
keep running
experiments um and third of all
I'm not just trying to make a better po
right I'm not just like trying to come
up with a from scratch a new algorithm
I'm trying to come up with something
that fixes one very specific problem
with generalized Advantage estimation
right I'm trying to fix this problem
where you have to sweep coefficients in
order to come up with credit
assignment so the
algorithm that I've come up with and
this is still work in
progress but if we get this working
whoops it will be the first
enduring contribution to RL algorithm
since
so in this paper right in GA you
do advantage
of
T
sum tal 0 where is it 0er to Infinity in
practice you go to
H Horizon
H gamma Lambda to the
L
gamma Lambda
L Sigma B
B plus
L all right so this is your normal
Advantage
function you're using gamma and Lambda
as these waiting
terms what I'm going to do instead is
I'm going to just get rid of Lambda
because I don't know it hurts my head uh
but I'm going to do something to replace
this I'm going to make
gamma be a
vector of size t or h more
specifically and then my value
function and their Val their value
function is a specific number right they
train the value function to match this
right so they try to do
expectation
T
equals R this is technically R because
when in advantage of T there's a uh you
know the the value function you have to
subtract I think the value Baseline so
it's like Advantage minus value or
something but they match the discounted
returns running sweep on GPU Drive
you're right setting log and reset did
that yeah always that
bug um I love how I don't even have to
read the code to know the
bug um okay so what are we going to do
with this algorithm we're going to make
the value function output a vector and
the value function is going to Output
at time T So evaluating value function
at time
T it's going to
Output
moo
zero moo
one
Mo
H
and it's going to also output Sigma
Z Sigma 1 Sig
H so now we have however many steps
we're going to roll forward for the
Horizon we have an estimate of the mean
value and an estimate of Sigma but I
haven't actually defined what we're
training this thing against yet so now
we're going to have a very simple
objective and this is where there are a
lot of different versions of this that
I've tried um but I think the absolute
simplest thing to do here is
expectation
V
T of
L so this is just
like you know expectation of an
individual element of
V equals
reward time t plus
oops in the
subscript that's all predict the next
just predict the next eight
rewards that's really easy to
compute and then the loss that we'll use
on this since we do have the sigma we'll
do a
gassian n l
L
of
moo Sigma and this is the
vector
Sigma
NL is this
loss
right it's just a loss that you apply to
um uh gaussian distribution outputs so
we're trying to match the reward but
there's also a variance term that we're
trying to tune as well so that we learn
the variance of our prediction we learn
the mean prediction
okay so that actually gives us a very
nice value function but the question is
what do we do with
it so the version of this that I've been
working on now that seems to be doing
stuff is also very simple much simpler
than the original generalized
estimation we just
advantage
T
sum zero H we don't have to Define this
Delta we don't have to do any of that
it's just going to
be
R uh was
it I equal
zero reward
I
minus
moo
I
Sigma squ
I so it is the
difference in your prediction divided by
your confidence in the in that
prediction that's all
this term if you're very confident in
all your
predictions this turns into predicting
average
reward which is exactly what you want
this turns into predicting average
reward which is theoretically actually a
problem with generalized Advantage
estimation is that it has it biases you
away from doing this so when you're
confident this is actually perfectly
correct uh and when you're not confident
this prevents you from caring about
rewards that you have no way of
predicting value function outputs mean
and standard deviation so you're pushing
your actor to predict the direct next
reward after you get that state the
actor has to predict the next reward the
next reward the next one it predicts the
next however many Rewards or critic sure
yeah they're just different heads to the
same network most of the time
anyways now there are a couple tricky
things with this um you know this needs
to be scaled so like in practice what I
do is I Define gamma but gamma is not a
hyper parameter anymore so I just do
equals
like 1
over Sigma I
2ar where is it divided by
Max one
over Vector squar so in practice I
normalized this so so that it has the
maximum gamma is one which is usually
going to be the first one cuz that's
your most confident prediction and then
the only other thing that I haven't
figured out yet here which is a little
tricky is what's this going to converge
to right this Sigma over time so if we
look at Sigma over time this is your
horizon this is the value of uh was it
one or gamma I guess
it doesn't go to zero it actually goes
to the variance of the reward so this is
like
VAR r i if you have no way of if you
have no prediction here if you just have
like no information whatsoever about how
to predict this value you'll just
predict the distribution so you end up
with this big gap and you end up waiting
terms that are way far out into the
Horizon by this value so I'm also
looking at you know subtracting
you can maybe do something like gamma
sub I minus
equals um
Alpha times this
value r i you can do something like this
I think it's technically like one over
this yeah so there's a little bit of
stuff with
normalization but uh this does actually
I already have runs where variations of
this fully solve breakout in about the
same amount of time as po it's just a
question of can we get this thing
generally working without tuning across
the board on a ton of different Ms you
don't want to wait too don't want to
wait too much terms which are are very
uncertain of yeah so the idea here is
that uh your advantage function doesn't
get really much credit for getting
rewards when it had uh when the policy
had absolutely no certainty about those
Rewards
right you only get credit for getting
rewards that you can
predict and by the way this is kind of
cool because this is adaptive right as
your policy gets better over time this
gamma function right instead of being
like this it'll be more like this
right because you'll be more confident
so you actually get a longer Horizon
over
time entropy of the distribution then
and plug that in if entropy is High your
weight should go down get entropy of
this distribution and plug that in if
entropy is high your weight should go
down so isn't that kind of what I'm
doing
here if I'm using this as a baseline
term so on its own right this the far
out predictions will converge to
variance of the reward this is variance
of the empirical reward like you can
just compute this over the batch of
rewards right or do like a running mean
of it or whatever
what what then what distribution would
you be taking entropy
Sigma the entropy of
well that distribution is over time
right Sigma I is following some
distribution entropy is high your weight
should go down well the entropy of Sigma
there are two possibilities here right
one is that you learn a single Sigma per
time
step so you just learn a waiting
function like as a function of how many
steps ahead you just learn a fix Sigma
for that that's what I've been doing
because that actually is way easier to
train uh but if you were to learn a full
If This Were to be like its own head of
the network that is per example I don't
think that you would want to do that
because you know it's possible that
you're very confident um in reward
predictions at certain times when you
are actually going to get a reward and
you don't know in other times where
there's genuine ambiguity so
I I don't know if you looking at the
entropy of the variant I think you're
just looking at the variance itself no I
could be missing something there
though so this experiment I have running
right now and then this one here is what
I was about to run on this box
hell this the cool out so this is the
algorithm I've been working
on let me figure out what's wrong with
this
Stu maybe I just have one I might
already have a
container the
heck ah
maybe I'm confused by what your gamma is
you're using it to scale the I term of
your at
correct yeah so I have I kind of clipped
it little right here so by default it's
just a normalized 1 over Sigma squ
so it's a learn term right it's just one
over the
variance of the I term
when you're trying to predict rewards
very far away in time your gamma is
going to just converge to the estimated
variance
yes and this isn't converging to zero so
that blows up the
sum um well it doesn't blow up the sum
because gamma max value is well it it
kind of blows up the sum a little bit
Yeah it kind of blows up the sum a
little bit not really any worse than
normal generalized Advantage estimation
but it kind of blows up the sum a little
bit it's not blowing up the sum that I'm
worried about it's more like you
shouldn't be putting equal you know a
constant equal amount of emphasis that
is one over the variance term on every
single thing forever you know ever and
ever for
so what do you
do what if your gamma equals scale it
down wait what do you do if
gamma hang on let me get my API token
for this
okay that should run what do you do if
gamma I
equals 1 over Sigma s i scale it down
by I I scale it down by the max of Sigma
of Sigma
squ so you look at all the different
gamma factors and then you scale down by
the max so the highest gamma I is going
to be one
lovely so now we have that
running let's see how the sweep is
going cuz we had uh I think from like 15
minutes
ago yeah there we
go oh that's cool so we already have
with the uh the other one that we
launched which does not subtract the
variance as a Baseline
so this one now is already solving the N
uh just in the last however many minutes
this is too expensive though so the goal
this and like I already sort of got
something with an older version of this
algorithm that mostly satisfies the
criteria I just don't think it has there
are a couple properties that make it a
little fiddly so I was trying to fix fix
that but um this is our best sweep from
Po and mind you this heavily relies on
tuning gamma and Lambda we're able to
solve this environment
in a minute and a half for
breakout so we'd like like obviously if
you tune gamma and
Lambda uh that's giving you some
additional information before you even
start the run so if it takes like 10 15%
longer in breakout I will be happy but I
would like this thing to just be really
really robust and stable to where like
you can run it with longer or shorter
effective Horizons and if you don't need
the extra Horizon it won't hurt your
performance um you know I would like
this to be really adaptive so that you
can see when you're running on more
complex environments with longer term
credit assignment you can see over the
course of training that the policy
learns a longer Horizon I'd like it to
just like you know the goal of puffer is
to fix RL and that doesn't mean like we
publish a paper that reports X higher
performance right because that's been
done for years these results don't
actually hold in practice right the goal
of this should be that when you use this
algorithm compared to
PO it should work with a lot less
fiddling and tuning and effort right it
should should just feel way more stable
and consistent that is the goal so that
when you have a new problem right you
throw this thing on it out of the box
it'll do something roughly reasonable if
you tune the hyper parameters that no
longer include gamma and Lambda it'll be
better that's a
goal that was fun story time I'll answer
questions on this while I wait for some
experiments and then we're going to
start the code review with Captain soon
um but since uh you know there's some
folks on here if you haven't already
started the repo please just start the
repo really really helps us out trying
to grow this as an open source project
and if you want to get involved with any
of this Dev just join the Discord like
heck most of these environments are made
by new contributors with no RL
experience
prior stuff goes pretty fast around
here love talking about this stuff yeah
I think we're really going to be able to
make RL better this here with the stuff
we're doing in puffer I mean here even
something just like as simple as this
algorithm like this hyperparameter sweep
this doesn't come from using random
search this doesn't come from using like
whatever crappy Basi and Optimizer out
of the box right this algorithm that
does this clean like look how clean this
hyper parameter sweep is right this is
on on PPO but still right even having to
tune Lambda and Gamma for
this this is just a really clean Cito
optimal front result right this
hyperparameter Optimizer took a few
weeks of work it's based on M Bui carbs
has a couple different Gan processes and
like thousands and thousands of little
experiments were run in order to get the
hyperparameter sweep algorithm itself to
a point where it can pretty consistently
to solve M like this um and it doesn't
have many of the pitfalls and the fiddly
bits in a lot of the other
algorithms
so good hyper parameter sweeps sanding
the rough edges off of
Po fast environments fast training you
know exhaustive experiments this is how
we fix
RL so at least this phase of fixing RL
I think once we get that done it'll
already be at the point where ARL will
become way more accessible to a ton of
different
stars I keep trying to think of ways to
really really get puffer out there um
it's tough though you know I keep uh I
try to keep stuff very on topic with RL
as best as I can and you know the
audience that's going to do RL is not
massive I think puffer is already if you
actually look at like the uh the star
Count versus a lot of other repos though
though like this is bigger than I think
it's actually even bigger than
Pearl oh no it went up
okay but still it's like more than half
the size of like thing for which they
bought a booth and stuff at NPS and you
know widely promoted using all of meta's
advertising and whatnot
so I don't know it's been doing pretty
it's been doing pretty
well but we need to do more we need to
do more because I really want to ship
all the new improvements so that users
have faster training Dev is about two or
three times faster training than um 2.0
right
now and this hyper parameter stuff is
really really nice and simple we're just
going to have to like I think the goal
is going to be to ship stable
sweeps this new algorithm if I get it
working widely broadly new baselines two
or three new environments that we are
working on merging uh as puffer 2.5 I
think that's going to be the
goal
so versus 20 up to 3x faster single GPU
training supports distributed training
uh new improved version of Po right so
new
algorithm new hyper parameter sweeps uh
Neptune integration monitoring with like
better
dashboards two awesome new environments
plus a couple smaller
ones that would seem like a good size
update for the first chunk of the
Year think that's what the goal will be
where's
author R
M's check that episodic counts also
works
at uh
oops it does look like I have a small
bug
here you might want to remove the
clamping okay
that he said to remove
this and remove
we'll see how that
does where's Captain already we have a
really cool environment to code review
soon whenever he's
back fiddle with this little in the
meantime
so this is
po doesn't do much on this size of a
hasn't gone completely to zero like the
other one I think
right maybe it's
ready in a minute
awesome good
I'm still thinking about your advantage
idea do you mind explaining where you
plug yeah one
it where you want to plug Gam in your
advantage so this is the entire
Advantage right gamma is basically just
normalized 1 over Sigma s so this term
here like this term is gamma that's
all so it's like another way of writing
this right would just be like
um a t
okay is Captain waiting in
Discord he
is hey
Captain hey can you hear me yeah I hear
you watching the stream as
well okay now it I got that figured out
right don't hear the stream anymore yeah
you're good cool we've been doing lots
of
Dev yeah um I haven't really done what
popping but I might check it out later
because I see you
explained uh like P30 pretty and yeah I
did like a really in-depth it's on the
VOD right yeah I'll catch up on it later
I think but yeah it's cool yeah so I
went through that that was fun um I
don't know I just do that stuff once in
a
while and we also
have's
it we have a couple different
experiments going
yeah I saw the e3b authors in Discord
that's pretty cool yeah I was asking him
some stuff because I haven't been able
to get that algorithm to work yet so it
would be nice if that algorithm
worked for sure I to be fair I just got
like some very very faint Signs of Life
After applying the fixes that you
suggested but I it needs to be like yeah
there need to be something much more
significant than
the other thing is that it's kind of
slow um like it actually does add
noticeable overhead as
well is that just how the algorithm is
designed in general or is that just like
your implementation I maybe we could
optimize it to be fair maybe we could
write a kernel for it because you don't
have to back propop through it um but it
is like a big Matrix
operation yeah I I guess cuz I don't I
haven't really looked into it all but I
guess it's just adding Rewards so yeah
nothing extra to train right um except
that in order to compute the reward you
do a big Matrix like you do a you're
doing a first order approximation to a
big Matrix
inverse um is it does it just the
algorithm does it just work for any M or
it is an approximation to count spaced
exploration so it okay you can use it on
any M whether it works on any
n it depends whether like soft
approximation of count space exploration
is good there yeah that makes sense
so it it'll run in any way and whether
it'll actually like you know improve
learning is another matter yeah so
generally like we were looking at e3b
because we had a one of our
collaborators wanted it um I didn't see
anything and I saw that it like was slow
so I didn't really push it too far um
but you know if it is a nice general
purpose enhancement then we could
potentially keep that in here and it
could be
nice um
okay uh code
review oh so let me show you something
real fast
um I couldn't help myself I was uh well
something you said yesterday kind of
reminded me of a weapon idea about like
something I've been considering for a
while yeah how easy be that's sick me
see green
to um smoother video and uh for the
folks watching this is
a we did you send the screenshot before
in
here uh I think you did yeah I
think well they'll here watch my screen
they can see it live for a second
because I'm just I want to show off like
yeah honestly need a better screenshot I
got that quick it was eh well we're
going to get you some nice Graphics I'm
gonna help you with that yeah um like
when you put this much time into an end
I at the least I can do is put some time
in as
well so the idea of what I was thinking
is like some kind of like black hole I I
spent like 30 minutes on it so it's not
like
really they like it's solving thebody
problem
the what it's solving the nbody
problem Yeah so basically there's like I
didn't render it but there's a space
around them where they just suck stuff
in that's so freaking
cool yeah it crashes now because of
stuff but yeah that's so okay that's so
cool um so what's funny is I think
actually to solve this crash because
what how I implement this
is um basically when I create the
projectile I create like a sensor on it
and that's that's like that's the way in
box 2D if you want to detect a collision
but not actually have it actually
Collide you know you just want to do
something with it use a sensor so I Mark
okay something um is on the sensor okay
until it leaves the sensor we're going
to apply like a sucking Force to it but
the downside is whenever like a
projectile gets destroyed I have like a
list of entities in each projectile um
that you know these entities are in the
black holes like radius and so I can
have like a use after free there um
which isn't easy to fix but I was
looking into the box 2D and I think I
can borrow something they do and
actually um do a little bit of static
well not static allocation but more
pulled allocation mhm so what they do
that's pretty cool um when you get body
IDs is it here yeah so basically they
have this basically Dynamic array of
body IDs they're just integers um and I
guess it's just kind of like a stack
based thing like when you free one it
can be reused again and they have bodies
that can be reused so um they allocate
like say 32 bodies up front and then
when they need more they'll create more
but when bodies get destroyed they can
reuse the memory but the bodies have an
ID from the ID pool and a generation so
you can kind of tell like oh is this
thing valid or not if that makes sense
because if you reuse yeah yeah so you
probably seen this before this is kind
of new to me which is cool so I might
use this I mean I've seen yeah I've seen
memory pool stuff like that I it's
that's kind of just like static with
indexing if you think about yeah I mean
the memory pool stuff I've worked with
but the what's new to me is like that
the idea of using IDs and then you can
kind of check like oh is this ID valid
or not and if it's valid you know you
get stuff if it's not so in this case
well that's how you would do uh I mean
that's how you would Implement a memory
pool right yeah like if you were being
smart about it right it would just be a
static chunk of memory and if you're
just storing fix size stuff in you just
need to know what rows you have free
MH but yeah I think this would solve my
problem because instead of storing
a list of like pointer two entities in
the projectiles that black holes need I
just store a list of um like entity IDs
and then when I'm iterating over them I
could check is this entity valid if not
I'll delete it from this list that I
have and if it is I'll you know apply
Force to it um that weapon looks really
cool by the way that looks cooler than
any of the other ones you've
implemented you think so if you did that
in 30 minutes then it's like you should
think about some of like some cool stuff
you can let like if you're going to have
this chunky physics engine you may as
well get some mileage out of it well
that's not even expensive right like
that's one like that doesn't even have
many
projectiles yeah probably the machine
gun is the one that's slow as hell yeah
because it's just a million projectiles
yeah I I've done benchmarks where they
just start off with the machine gun and
it's like slow as crap because it's just
so many
yeah but yeah I I think the potential
for this
is I honestly wonder if the machine gun
should bounce it does no I wonder if it
should though oh because it's so many
bloody projectiles it just floods the
screen maybe the trade-off is that they
don't
bounce maybe they on impact like if
you like they only bounce one so it's
not that big of a deal
I mean I know I think that's kind of
like all right I mean yeah I can think
about it I'm just wondering if that
wouldn't even help you that much CU it
would maybe cut like half the Lifetime
on average yeah if they bounce
once yeah the triangles are cool as well
yeah I know I you stuff like the spawn
animation adds a lot no I know it it
really does and the triangles were kind
of wait the they don't why doesn't it
affect oh it does yeah it's it's just
not in the radius and I haven't rendered
the radius because like I said I barely
spent any time on it yeah we should add
stuff for man yeah we should add stuff I
I think that what we're going to do for
this is this will be like the Box 2D EV
valve project I'm not going to like want
you to rearchitecturing
at what box 2D is actually doing to see
like if it's making you write more code
than you need to write because that will
drive me insane until I like basically
until I'm given very strong evidence
that this API isn't the thing that's
causing you to have to write like three
times too much to code I'm just going to
think that so I will check that at some
point because like if I check it I I
give it 50/50 that I'm right right and
if I am right that makes it way easier
for us to write physics based stuff in
the future doesn't it mhm so yeah
potentially well okay what would be the
what would be the alternative it though
if we decided like we're not going with
box 2D in the future just find some
other thing or try we use box 2D but
like it might just be that I can rip out
the core stuff that actually is perf
like that is important to perf stick it
in like a thousand line utils file that
just does the heavy like the the physics
parts that are complex and then you just
write your own loops and then you end up
with you end up with half the code
because you don't have any boiler
plate to be fair though if you really do
have that opinion after looking more
into it which to be honest um I think
you might
personally uh I would talk with the Box
three author first because obviously
he's not going to be willing to totally
redesign the API but he might yeah he's
pretty open to suggestions in general
and just you might exping those
functions for instance maybe or some
kind of compromise that will you know
okay maybe make it more amicable in both
parts but we'll see he he's he's pretty
cool um like I said I've had multiple
times where I've had issues or found
bugs or whatever and he's fixed them
pretty fast when I can give him a good
Repro or just people in there generally
pretty helpful like well what I would do
right is I would like I'd probably go
try to find the functions I need I'd
like put them into a short file and like
we'd see like okay can build an end with
this and i' be like hey like do you
think that you could expose these
functions as you like these pieces of
code AS Standalone functions and then I
could just use them from box 2D and then
you just have like a lightweight API
that exposes the uh like the actual math
parts that are hard to implement without
having to use your whole
Loop right that would be the nice way of
doing it so then it gets
upstreamed oh by the way um I think I
have an idea of how we can test the
theory of like uh of what is very slow
in box 2D so I was looking in just I
don't know various stuff because I was
trying to figure out how they did like
the um ID pooling stuff and there is a
Boolean toggle when you create a world
like do you want to enable continuous
Collision detection like globally at all
um and my thought is if we turn that off
off and I'm I'm testing it right now the
collisions definitely aren't as good and
I wouldn't do this for the main game
like you know normally but I bet if we
turn that off we get a lot of perf like
I bet that turn it off for training and
see if it works well enough uh no
because a lot of stuff would tunnel but
I'm just wondering if we just do another
test and see hey is this
actually but I'm I'm willing to bet
that's most of it because given what GPR
said you know solving continuous or
whatever was like most of the time the
runtime
yeah and the stuff I'm proposing
probably wouldn't
even like the stuff I'm proposing
wouldn't even make box 2D faster right
no it literally it would but it would
make it easier to see where stuff is
slow yeah
right I don't it's not worth doing for
this project right it's easier to just
find the things that are slow but just
in general I think it would it would
make a big difference
yeah I mean definitely if anything right
seeing like the amount of code that is
is required for uh like a like a top
down 2D physics it's like three times
almost three times the amount of code or
two and a half times the amount of code
for neural MMO right like the extent to
which we're going to be able to write
like more M like this is going to be
hampered by that right I mean this is
like an a this is like a herculan effort
from you to get something of this size
done
um like there's a lot of freaking code
to have to write and maintain for you
it is and to be fair I I'm not totally
disagreeing with what you're saying but
at the same
time in some ways on the surface I think
this game is less complex than neural
MMO you actually go get into it and get
into implementation details I think it
is even without you know say what you
will about box CS API whatever I think
it is a little bit more complex with
just all the edge cases all the weapons
all the stuff going on you know so even
if we could
I don't know shrink down the bullet
plate and stuff I think it still would
be longer still more complex I don't
know it might end up being I mean
there's a lot of stuff in neural MMO
there's like a dozen different types of
items um equipment all works differently
there are you know internal combat stats
for damage CS there's a whole market and
there's like a like literally a dynamic
market right in which players can list
stuff on auction and stuff list stuff
for auction and whatnot um um the PCG
for this it's like a combination of
three separate algorithms for PCG for
neural MMO uh the rendering which is
like a good chunk of neural MOS code is
crazy because of the tile Cals to get
like all the animations to line up yeah
so there's like stuff for that yeah so I
mean like if you include everything I
don't know I wouldn't know if I I
wouldn't be sure that it's like I I
definitely don't think it's like on the
surface you look at the two games which
one has two times more codee than the
other right yeah I I don't know if I
would say that especially if you're not
saying if you said oh I rolled my own
physics engine and that's part of the
game code then sure yeah right but it's
not that but I'm not that crazy
yeah not that good
me
uh so you want to pick off where you
left or yeah pick up where we left off
yesterday
G.H yeah and we were I think you were
just about to finish the explosion yeah
so we
around I remember from
yesterday
perfect oh okay it does give you line
number in the bottom right okay that's
nice it just doesn't give you the line
number on the sides I don't want to
waste the extra four five
characters fair enough
um
cool oh so note that uh the shape
projected perimeter I honestly need to
look into that a little bit so this
explosion
callback uh box 2D does have I think he
said it's kind of experimental I was
using it for a while they have some code
that you can basically just say like hey
explode stuff in this area but I needed
more fine-tune control because of like
handling bursts and uh other explosions
differently and then some other stuff I
just um I yeah it just made more sense
for me to handle all of it myself so
some of the code is just copied like the
logic is kind of copied from that
explosion call back yep um so I guess
like he scales the impulse of the
explosion based on the perimeter of the
shape which I actually come to think of
it I don't want to ask him about that
that's interesting but not sure why
exactly he does that he's scales the
explosion by the
perimeter of what shape uh of this so in
this um callback right now um
basically yeah so basic this callback
like the parent function is an a bounds
check and anything in the bounds is
being so any entity any rigid body
actually any shape in the uh bounded
area that I ask for is being called with
my call back so uh and it's based on a
filter I give it so this is any
projectiles drones or floating walls uh
their shapes so um we're we're basically
processing like what oh so it's I think
it's trying to
do I guess it's trying to is it like
trying to
approximate the amount of force that
should be applied yeah okay I think it's
an approximation I
like
oops if you have a line and then you
explode
here right and if this is in range then
this is going to be pushed farther than
if you have like a point or something cu
the force gets yeah but like it's not
actually the perimeter it should
actually be like a cast Ray cast check
or whatever I think they're just using
perimeter for the hell of it because if
the line is in the other direction right
then it's like it shouldn't be pushed
almost at
all Yeah well yeah I mean the bunch of r
r checks would be pretty expensive maybe
there's a way I could do it more
efficiently but
like yeah I'm not not the Box 2D isn't
for that's the this is the reason why
I'm suspicious about perf right because
it's like box 2D isn't doing crazy stuff
like this yeah
right yeah um I don't know maybe maybe
there are I wonder I'll have to ask him
about that I'll have to maybe after we
get done with this review we can do a
test like Bas just disable continuous or
CCD globally and see how much that
affects things and if it's mostly CCD I
can just ask him be like well I know I
do know he released box 3 3.0 in uh
August I believe of 24 so pretty
recently um and since then I'm working
off like just master or whatever or main
or whatever Branch um so he's had a lot
of like speed improvements and Bug fixes
and stuff since then and one of the
things he did improve was continuous
closing detection so it used to be even
slower and apparently version three is a
lot than version two because he focused
more on performance and added simd
support and some other stuff but yeah I
don't know maybe okay that's cool
because we're not even doing simd in
like any of our M anywhere and they're
still as fast as they are yeah I mean
that's just because they're so simple I
think to be honest like not you know not
downplaying the efforts of whoever
created them but there's just you know
not a lot happening in a neural MMO is
1.9 million steps per second per cor
that's why I said a lot of them neural
MMO and MOA are kind of the exceptions I
think but I'm still not doing simd and
they're just as fast if not faster than
some of the others right yeah true good
point yeah I like yeah it's if I don't
know it's kind of Interest that's kind
of interesting to see I want to play
more with some 7D stuff at some point
but cool yeah it yeah
anyway okay um yeah I want to go through
this in a decent clip today because I
think we are going to want to spend some
time talking about the renderer when we
get there and I mean like I want to look
at stuff like how easy animations are to
load in with RB can I go commission you
an animation set for this right stuff
like that would be awesome
so we want to yeah we can talk about
that when we get
there so do you vaguely remember what
happened as function or do you need to
like like uh I probably should just like
quickly yeah just blow through
it oh that was the initial reason I
didn't that's right the initial reason I
created this call back was uh you could
basically just
pass when the normal explode thing you
could only say like oh explode all
shapes of this type but I wanted to do
more granular filtering like uh that's
right for bursting I wanted to say don't
explode the parent drone but explode
every other parent drone or every other
drone but you can't do that so and then
I kept adding a bunch of stuff so it
made a lot more sense anyway
so you use the closest point to
determine the force yep and I went over
with it yesterday we we do that I do
that so that I can accurately determine
whether the shape is in the explosions
range or not because their Center could
be pretty far from the closest
point relatively speaking
yeah I sadly did uh I took I did not
take the uh the undergrad physics core
at uh Stanford and just sad now because
I think it was actually pretty
good yeah I had to take calculus based
pH physics and undergrad and I didn't
care for I didn't I wasn't yeah I was
thinking I was never going to use it so
I didn't really learn much I mean you
get a little bit in high school if you
do the AP right it is calculus based
physics yeah I didn't do AP stuff
unfortunately but the undergrad courses
are better so I lost out on that but
yeah I don't know it seems like a lot of
this is like relatively simple physics
that you just have to get very correct
yeah to be honest most of what is
exposed to you is like you know box HTI
handles the hard stuff from what I
understand all the stuff you have to
deal with for the most part at least in
this in this game is is just math once I
kind of got a handle on some basic
Vector math it was not bad but
everything was new to me so it took a
while to get going but well it's funny
like that so you're saying this is an
explosion but there isn't like there's
not like a radial impulse
thing that you can make is
there uh well there's no
so what you mean like just applying an
Impulse just I mean I kind of having
like a like there isn't like a
blast like function or whatever because
there would be more complex physics
behind that if you wanted to handle it
more
correctly oh like I said they do have an
easy explode like B2 explode thing but
it makes a lot of assumptions so
I just okay I wonder what the physics is
behind that because like you know
there's a really simple way to implement
that and then there's like a more
correct but harder way to implement that
so like my version is honestly in most
cases more complex just because of me
handling some edge cases but the whole
like parent
velocity direction thing I added that
wasn't in the original so in some cases
mine is more complex but there are some
edge cases that they account for and
version that I just know I won't hit in
my game so I just removed um but I don't
know how would you think it would be
more
accurate well like the perimeter thing
we just went over is one thing yeah um I
don't know if it's
like yeah I don't know where if you take
into account Center of mass if you take
into account the nearest contact point
but there's like stuff you can see that
you'd probably have to do
there oh so when I I kind of cheat in
this way think because I don't think
this is totally accurate but I haven't
thought too much about it wouldn't be
hard to do the other way basically when
I at the bottom of this function when I
finally calculate what the impulse is I
just apply it to the center Center of
mass or whatever shape I don't bother
applying it to like the closest point
but I could very easily do that I just
apply it to center of mass I don't know
if that Chang the other funny thing is
you're not actually trying to make a
physics engine here you're trying to
make a game and like name the number of
games that you know that are good
because have good physics versus the
number of games that you know that are
good because they have dodgy physics
right oh 100% no that's what I'm saying
I have to I'd have to see if that
changed anything nobly I I don't think
it matters for the actual game be
fair yeah I uh oh shoot this
um I watched a pretty interesting video
uh GDC talk on Rocket League physics and
they did some networking but it was
interesting because they initially
started out talking like okay you know
if you're going to realis assimilate a
car here are all the forces and stuff
you have to handle and then they they
said okay but for Rocket League we want
the cars to be super Snappy and this and
that you know they need to turn fast
accelerate fast break Fest so they're
not going to be physically accurate so
like when they when the player presses
the throttle they don't apply torque to
the wheels they just apply a forward or
backwards Force to the center mass of
the vehicle yeah of course like the
games actually bother I mean maybe Forza
does or something maybe Forza actually
bothers doing
that but it was just interesting going
over some of the other things because I
think they said someone wanted an actual
like transmission and the dev team was
you know having to handle all this stuff
like changing gears and there you know
this I guess who's giving the talk it
was a uh guy he worked at like a physics
consulting firm so I guess they were
contracted out to help with rocket
League a lot they didn't rate the engine
but they just helped them with a lot of
the physics and they just said okay guys
we don't need a transmission let's just
you know make some kind of acceleration
curve and that's way
easier yeah transmission there's a
couple other interesting things we need
to simulate Transmission in our soccer
car game yeah I mean you can see the
thinking there right it's like oh it's a
car it's got to have a transmission but
no so dumb though like uh yeah
okay um
anyway
yeah see I can explain that comment
right there if you need that one so
basically last velocity and
speed current velocity will
be the
velocity you actually handle like this
is like a frame perfect
is this like to handle if you like
explode and hit something on the same
frame no uh kind of so
basically uh normally so when you shoot
projectiles if okay if I shoot a
projectile and it's going to bounce
multiple times and I and you know we're
both players I hit you if you just
normally have box two to simulate it
what makes sense is I guess like I
forget what Newton's law this is but
basically you know uh I hit you with
something and there's enough restitution
the projectile is going to bounce off
your player your player's going to be
pushed one way and the projectile is
going to be pushed the other way but
some of the force you know the
projectile is not going to be going as
fast now because some of the force was
transferred into pushing the player
right well that totally depends that
depends on um I mean if you throw like a
big mass of clay or something at
somebody it'll transfer all the force
yeah I'm just saying generally because
in this simulation like things have
enough restitution to bounce off yeah
okay so I don't want that to happen
because there was a lot of times where
you'd shoot floating walls or other
players and depending on how the
Collision happened the projectiles go
slow down to a crawl which was confusing
and also not very interesting so
basically you'll see it when you go
further down whenever a projectile coll
Ides with something else um I make sure
it speed either stays the same or
increases I don't let it slow down so
okay because sometimes it can hit
something and then basically be like
crawling and it's like why did my shot
do that um the original game doesn't do
it often but I have seen it happen and
it took a while to work out all the edge
cases of that but I think the game's
better for it personally
and this could happen with the explosion
too right so say the projectile is
coming straight down from top to bottom
and you have an explosion at the bottom
of the screen pushing it up and say it's
exactly the same Force you know it's
going down at like this is probably the
wrong math but it's going down at like
you know speed of like 50 or something
and the impulse is 50 so then it's just
standing still um that's yeah so in this
case it just push it
upwards okay
so it's not accurate but it's more fun I
mean this is kind of cool you've
actually done like a ton of physics
tweaks just to be like yeah but what if
the laws of physics bent to my will to
make this actually fun yeah that's kind
of cool I mean that's just how Game Dev
is right I mean like you said you don't
want it to make it accurate you want to
make it fun yeah and ACC it's funny to
spend like the amount of time in the
physics code specifically looking for
that right that's cool well I mean most
of this game is physics so makes sense
like there's not a lot yeah a decent
chunk of it is just physics handling if
the physics sucks the game
sucks well no if the physics is good the
game probably
sucks yeah I'm if the if if the physics
isn't what I mean by sucks if the
physics is somewhat predictable and also
interesting then the game has a better
potential to be good but the physics is
unpredictable or you know maybe it's so
realistic it's kind of it subverts your
expectations like that you shoot someone
and then your bullet is like super slow
it's not very fun
so appearance entity velocity effects
the direction impulse depending on speed
okay Shield
reduction yeah so explosions take away
some of the Shield health what Shield so
Shields it's only used used when you
spawn in or respawn uh it's just like a
thing around players it's just basically
so you can't just get spawn killed oh
that's funny you actually it's not just
like immune for three seconds it
actually has Health that's funny yeah to
be fair though it's I mean it it
definitely is able to be broken like if
you hit a sniper shot at it it'll break
um and there is a penalty for it being
broken it takes away like right now a
third of your energy but it doesn't
happen very often but
yeah you also can't predict where things
spawn no but I mean if you're quick
enough on the draw I mean you have three
seconds when people someone spawns to
break their
Shield maybe I should punish the player
that has their Shield broken more I
don't know maybe it take a heftier
energy penalty or something not sure but
nah I don't know probably not
okay here it
isar
impulse a static
Ball So yeah so this is an
explosion uh and it's up against a wall
then it's reflected okay I see so be um
normally if it's a normal explosion I'm
never going to allow static walls are
basically never going to be in this
callback because the filter won't even
allow it to be processed but if it's a
burst that's the only way it'll get
processed so if we have a static wall in
here we know we're bursting
basically just the whole rest of the
function
so the whole impulse per length is
greater than it basically the imploder
will not set off a mine
they don't I would like there to be some
visual differentiation between
explosions and implosions but the way I
thought of it is you know explosions
setting off all explosions but
implosions are just like sucking so that
wouldn't really set off the
mine we'll come up with some I I'll help
you on some fun graphic stuff because
there's so much physics in here it's
going to be tough for me to like come up
with good stuff to do here
I can definitely do stuff on the graphic
side for sure yeah and um I mean that
might even give you new ideas for
weapons and fun stuff or also we should
just train we should also just start
training on it
but I think make it look good and start
training on it would be priority I mean
live service game gets
updates buy the battle
pass oh my gosh I'm not selling my Souls
no you're selling the battle
pass same thing
yeah I'm just I'm just fitting in my
head to like where this would be getting
called
gotta it's interesting they just like
there are a lot of cases where you're
like like a lot of the special casing
here is because you're fighting with the
physics engine that has its roles and
like it you know things are updated
according to physics like except here
and here and here and here like MH yeah
I
see yeah for point I understand that's
pretty common because I mean the physics
engine isn't making any assumptions it's
just trying to simulate physics somewhat
accurately and you have a very specific
vision for your game which probably
isn't going to fall you know in order
for you to achieve your vision you don't
want 100% accurate physics
yeah like these calls and stuff I
like I mean this is just a Setter
honestly I don't think this does
anything do you know why there are all
these Setters and getters why it's not
just like drone like VX or
whatever is there something where like
the Drone is like this is not actually
the physics object and it's like in the
world somewhere or
something because I don't understand why
they're all
these like why doesn't this drone like
Arrow
velocity why isn't the Drone what like a
lot of these F like why isn't this just
drone Arrow velocity is there like an
engine reason why like this drone isn't
the same drone object that's actually in
the world or something
weird well so
um I guess the way they separate it they
have body
IDs which point or which basic uh are
are not point because they're not
pointers but you know they I guess like
reference or whatever body data which
has stuff like velocity and you know all
the the simulation stuff
and I don't know they don't give you
that object because they don't want you
messing with it so they just kind to
have functions that lets you set certain
things because there's a lot
of again that's that's one of those
reasons where there's a ton of State
information they have and they only
expose the parts that are like generally
useful to avoid people messing with
stuff they generally shouldn't going to
shoot themselves in the foot yes but
Getters and Setters are ALS so kind of
ccer um sure there's not a ton of them
though I was just like I'm just like
wondering why like I keep seeing all
these calls I keep having to
process I generally don't get or set the
lar I really don't get the lar velocity
very often I mostly do it in handle body
movement now um but it's pretty rare
that I actually get it outside of there
I'm just doing it here because I know
the VY is in um updated because I just
implied applied an Impulse which
directly updates the velocity um if you
apply a force though so in box 2D you
have impulses and forces and impulses
are just immediately a change to the
velocity and a force is actually
simulated like when you apply a force to
a body I don't know the simulator
handles it somehow I oh I they have
substeps so like say you have four
substeps apparently the the force is
like spread out over those substeps
during one World update step so um but
yeah so forces are if you want to do
something potentially across multiple
steps impulses is just a one shot like
just you know I'm shoving you versus I'm
pushing you over the floor or
but but yeah I really don't hardly ever
apply forces I only apply like a force
when uh you move the Drone with the you
know just moving it and well you're kind
of just setting a bunch of velocities
then and um you're really only using the
engine for like sub stepped Collision
detection I
guess there's a couple other things but
that's the main thing also you know like
bouncing yeah Collision detection bounds
checking um I mean a couple other things
it's there's a lot of things I I yeah I
don't know but yeah I'm not using a ton
like I'm not using you know utilizing
utilizing box to a full extent that's
for sure but this would be very this
game would not like be barely anything
if I had to do the physics from scratch
well yeah because there's like there
like you'd have to have like a nice
bounding box hierarchy which is going to
be like a quadry or some other data
structure yeah you'd have to have very
optimized Collision checks um there are
a few other physics bits in there as
well yeah but it's tough because like
I'm trying to review the code and every
damn criticism I have is a criticism of
box 2D not your code
yeah so yeah now you can see where I
actually call the explosion like look
even when you have the opportunity to
you even do this it's like you can't
even you just can't you just don't even
have the syntax with uh the Box 2D
like you even use the nice struct
initializer Syntax for stuff when you
can it's just boxd doesn't let you a lot
of the time right
yeah but I mean yeah when you get um
body definition or whatever definitions
like I get it because they set the
defaults in a function so I don't blame
I mean a lot like this is like exactly
how I'd write this I just Grumble more
than you over like some of the
stuff other than that like yeah the
minor stuff we don't have to care too
much so yeah destroying projectile
is like a whole Rabbit
Hole um sometimes I want to just destroy
the body but not process explosions
because I already process explosions for
it's it gets really complicated so
process explosion is pretty
self-explanatory the F Boolean I have
that in a couple things that's mostly
just an
optimization sometimes um if I'm just
like tearing not the world down if I'm
if I'm ending it
um an episode
basically uh I'm going to be just
basically setting the whole array size
to zero so there's no need to
individually remove elements from the
array that's all that's saying basically
just like a tiny
optimization I could probably name full
something a little better but
I'm actually really starting to get
understand how your code is and like how
you're writing stuff now
finally
um yeah the sudden wall stuff took me a
bit to get right and this part of the
code might be a little bit messy because
I don't know it just kind of worked and
I'm like okay it
works I still need do corner case
basically the entire map is is covered
and W just the game like there could
because I have multiple lives there
there can be a case where um players are
in the middle of like respawning and the
whole wall like the whole map is covered
in wall
and so the game's not over so then the
game tries to place more subth walls
even though the entire map is covered in
walls and then then just crashes so
pretty easy thing to handle
though basically you will hit any Edge
case that's possible because you're
running billions of steps so exactly I
had this thing with like neuro and stuff
a fancy
s stuff
happens it's nice though it's almost
it's almost kind of like fuzzing
um like you're bound to find tons of
bugs you wouldn't have otherwise found
I do need to update that I thought I did
because now it's Tech that's technically
not true if they have multiple lives I
need to update that a little
bit Yeah that would like just insta end
theh but before with one life it was
always true
so
yeah it makes sense I guess for the main
game um
mhm generally just having like
continuous respawning stuff is going to
make your life a lot easier for
RL as long as you don't get into weird
map states over a long time like long
bits of time but that's just like pure
Eng though I it is annoying like you can
end up if you make really big Maps
you'll end up with stuff where like
they'll all go to one side of the map or
something and it'll just like Mosh Pit
yeah I can see that I've had that with
snake a
bunch how did you solve
that you just keep training better
models until it goes
away um I think I don't know if I still
do it I think I neural MMO I will
randomly respawn agents once in a
while okay like just I'll like like
every time you make a move there's a
small chance you just get moved
somewhere or whatever
I think I called it telor titis yeah a
ttis yeah I think I remember seeing that
in the code and I was like what the heck
is this teleport titis it's from
Noida what's NOA NOA is this oh you if
this is like king of all physics games
honestly so every pixel in the
environment is physically
simulated what
so every single Pixel like stuff burning
like the M
Burns crumbles flows every pixel
shatters so every single Pixel is
physically
simulated that's crazy yeah and it's
like a ludicrously
unforgiving uh big Rog
like
huh that looks awesome it is an awesome
game it is incredibly frustrating as
well uh
it's yeah it's kind of crazy the stuff
you can do in that game like you know
the uh the what is it like the parallel
universes meme from Mario yeah yeah yeah
so this game it parallel universes but
unironically oh my gosh they kicked it
up to 11 it's actually yes like yeah
it's you should play it it's fun but uh
I can't imagine
the code parallel
universes that's insan and it's like the
type of thing where like there's this
massive map that you can just look up
for all the exploration stuff and then
you go like oh but I don't want to spoil
it cuz like it's so cool to discover
this stuff but it's like at the same
time it's
like in Dark Souls you could technically
find everything on your own in this
there's no way in how you
do so interesting so this is a rogue
like without a pregenerated or yeah
generated it is uh there are it is
generated but there are like structural
elements in regions that are going to be
in the same places every time oh okay
gotcha so like you can be like if I go
to this point in this area of the map
there will be this thing
here and that thing might be randomly
generated itself but like that area will
be the same and the stuff that's in it
will be from the same pool or whatever
yeah and maybe the journey to get there
will be different every time but or what
you see way whatever that's kind of cool
nice compromise it is also incredibly
frustrating because you can play like 20
hour runs in this thing and can just
like instantly die even if you're like
stacked man so like there's basically
there's never a point in the game where
you can't just instantly
die and okay so it's not like Hades or
anything where you can kind of get
strong like you can you know slowly kind
of build up strength between runs and
and enter run stronger like it's a base
yeah you just start from scratch every
time it's there's way less progression
yes yeah okay there are a couple very
small progression elements but they're
almost
meaningless
interesting yeah I'll check it out that
looks cool I it's a fun game there's no
way in hell to run it fast enough for RL
though oh yeah I was thinking the same
thing no way honestly even though it is
2D they probably had to play with perf a
lot with all the stuff they're simul
that game you can lag that game on the
machine I'm running right now yeah I can
imagine that is a game you can have I
you might be able to have infinite
projectiles in that
game like there're it's it's actually
it's probably the coolest implementation
of magic I've ever seen in a game
because this isn't spoiling anything you
build your own
wants oh so you build your own spells
and you can literally build like yeah
you can build wands that like teleport
you to different universes
literally and not like there isn't like
a button that does that either like you
basically have to program your wand to
do that that's really cool that sounds
like the the biggest like nerd snipe of
a
game it kind of is but also it's like
it's also just like so hard to figure
these things out on your own it's not
even it's not even like the typical nerd
snipe games where you could technically
figure this stuff out on your own like
you kind of just
can't yeah I'll definitely have checked
that out that's
yeah um I don't know anyways so games
you reminded me though really quick I
actually I wanted to see what you
thought about this because I've actually
thought about two new weapons in the
game cuz like I show you that black hole
weapon oh man there's so many things you
can do here glue gun uh freaking give it
roadhog hook for you know like you can
do so many things I was grappling hook
could be really hard I was thinking
about that but I have no idea how to
implement that um what I was thinking of
though um some kind of like teleporter
like basically the portal gun from
Portal mhm um I don't know how would
that work exactly I guess like whenever
it touches something it just places the
first thing it touches it places a
portal there and then you know second
time you place a second portal I don't
know that's hard because then you have
to be able to shoot through portals and
stuff yeah no honestly I think that'd be
really easy because basically when
something hits a portal to the other one
I guess yeah and then you just change
its the direction of its velocity based
on like the uh orientation of the other
portal I think that H to be really easy
wasn't there do you remember that FPS
that was literally like yeah split gate
is that what was called that it like
died instantly but it was really
cool yeah yeah they're coming out with
two soonish is this um the wait they got
money for this it died instantly on a
release yeah I don't know they they're
coming out with two soon it came out
when overwatched it and they just got
crushed oh was it I started playing it a
couple years like two or three years ago
so I play I know they servers on yeah
that looks cool it's it's fun to mess
around in um I saw because I just suck
at fpss but it's it's just the portal
concept is so cool yeah I've been trying
to get not terrible but it is
hard yeah I agree I know but yeah yeah I
don't know I get ner sniped super hard
by games because I suck at them and very
often it's just like dude your me your
mechanics are just that bad but it's
like I feel there's something to solve
it's like why can't I solve this game
right yeah yeah
oh were you able to order the controller
Fu a controller I forgot okay
uh do I have Amazon logged in if not I
have to go get TOA I do uh what which
controller do you
get um that's a good question I mean
isn't there a nice one that's like I
could just order the how much is the
razor
one razor
controller just make sure it plays nice
with nice with one
obviously oh jeez I don't even know if
that is a thing because I the
only let me think I mostly play with
this or you test with the switch Pro
Controller I really did not think it'd
work very well but supported for well in
RB and on Linux at least like uh pop OS
which I'm running um I know Xbox
controllers also work because I use that
with a friend um my brother-in-law has
like a
knockoff uh switch controller that did
not work at all like RB wouldn't really
detect it hecked the controller but half
the buttons didn't work but
uh oh the Razer Xbox
controller
interesting okay it doesn't let you buy
it that I see where the hell I'll buy
from retailers okay wait
140 I didn't see it
let me see how much is this
thing oh there's a pro version of it
too yeah so I think that one's
200 yeah it ain't that deep man the
controllers are I don't know why people
pay that much for
controllers I already had the one for a
switch because drycon suck and I want an
actual controller so I you buy one you
buy one that where the so they don't you
don't get freaking joycon drift yeah
exactly I'm trying to remember which one
I bought that I liked there was a damn
controller that I liked I can't remember
what the hell it was called oh do you
have it back in California or something
yeah yeah I wish I remembered what the
heck it was okay I'll have to find it
because there was a good controller I
can just buy that had like a nice rubber
ice back and
stuff
okay um anyways
then we should finish yeah you think you
think the idea of a teleporter weapon
would be kind like interesting you can
like the thing is you can infinitely
keep adding weapons yeah um at some
point like at some point with this
it's like you may as well just go do the
big maps and stuff if you're going to
keep doing that stuff
yeah at least at this point weapons are
fairly easy well I guess depends on how
big the scope of the weapon is something
like the teleport probably require a a
little a decent bit of code because it's
special case but I could add you know
variance of like oh this is a burst
rifle or something that'd be super easy
you could let you you could let the
people have like two or three weapons as
well I was I was thinking about that I
just don't know if I'm making the game
too complex at that point yeah you're
GNA you're GNA I think at this point
already you're going to just completely
Crush human players um now like
ironically you might make it to the
point where people can find strategies
that the Bots can't discover on their
own
um but yeah if you just keep cranking it
up people just going to get merked
instantly yeah it it's to the point now
whenever I try to show someone I I'm
halfway decent at it so I can I still
die stupid deaths but I can you know
kill my fair share of scripted or neural
network Bots but anyone I shows it that
I show it to who doesn't have any
experience with this or the original
game just gets destroyed but I remember
being there when I first played the
original game so yeah it's not totally
skill issue I honest
I think that you can take this really
far but if you are going to take this
really far then you should put the
effort in to make it fast enough so that
we can like let's get training going at
the rate that our other M are training
yeah our other complex M at least right
and uh also this thing is not going to
work with multi-gpu right now because
you're going to be hard Bott neck by CPU
yeah so you know there's there's it's
not just like no reason to ever make it
faster no you can like you keep getting
benefit by making making it faster um oh
I agree I've spent a lot of time trying
to optimize it I'm just kind of hit a
wall yeah so there's that and then let's
like let's actually make it look like
the thing it is right MH yeah like
there's no point in like if it's going
to be super super low fly and there
aren't going to be any cool animations
and stuff I would way rather see this
thing get like the current thing super
polished and then you have you be
excited to like work on bigger versions
of stuff and expand things if you want
to go that route um rather than you know
keep adding keep adding stuff to it but
you know the graphics still look really
way simpler than it is and you know it's
still kind of slow and stuff like that
um yeah fair enough so I would think
that that would probably be and I think
you'll have more fun doing this as well
because you'll get a little break and
you'll get to actually do like some
science and research side stuff with
puffer um and then you'll be able to
actually like see that on this game that
you've
made yeah all right I'll stop going off
in Tangent so you can keep going I'm
really bad with it
well
okay drone move it's just getting nerd
sniped constantly is all it is yeah I'll
just try not to make matters worse Dr
Center so when you move you do apply
Force because um you're potentially
moving over multiple steps so it has it
should be a force in box
Tod because forces get yeah a force
instead of an acceleration as well yeah
they call it Force but it is just
acceleration isn't
it uh I guess this is dependent on mass
yeah it is so this will just do the
division for you or whatever yeah you
just figure out how much force you want
to give it and then box C figures out
how going simulate it
okay that's not bad on its
own this is the slow one because it
spawns
break now this I actually want to see so
breaking does just a
damping yep it's basically just damping
and then a bunch of energy edge
cases you still get to damp
if oh no okay I see that's disables it
yeah there's always damping because
that's simulating friction it being top
down
when you get into it actually the actual
like core logic really isn't that bad so
far for the most part it's not it's just
there's so much freaking object creation
that's so funny that you found like edge
cases like this like
what like you're literally tracking the
projectile inside of a freaking sensor
range
oh yeah that edge case is really obvious
though if you don't handle
it because basically if that if you set
a mine and the mine is set on a wall and
a drone is in its radius but the walls
between them and then the Drone moves
into line of sight of the mine really
close um yeah you can have it so the
Drone can be right on top it nothing
happens which is makes no sense from a
gameplay perspective so yeah it's a very
obvious Edge case you know what another
really easy weapon to implement would be
that would be pretty
funny you could do trigger
mine like you place the mine and then
you trigger on will at will
yeah yeah I was thinking about being
able to do that or not yeah
like congratulations you implemented
jump
rat take a little 15 minute break you're
looking
tired I don't know I've gotten a fair
bit of exercise in
today maybe
that I want to finish this file first CU
then we'll be fresh for
rendering yeah you're pretty close at
this point I
think I honestly can't say I found a
single thing in your code which like
that's dumb you shouldn't have done it
that way
that's good would like to hear uh kind
of I mean I guess yeah it's good for you
not to find anything well I mean to be
fair this is also this is true of like
zero code bases from anybody I know at
Stamford or MIT and like any of the RL
code I read
online
um so that
is or any code by anyone at
Fang um
so this is like this is
solid thanks I'll take it the like again
it's like I have large criticisms but
they're criticisms of Bo
2D
so to be fair it's like I maybe if I
were to look at the way like there's too
much code for me to even see what
functions you've defined and like how
they interact cuz like so maybe there's
like some higher level thing but I can't
freaking see because there's too much
code yeah yeah makes
sense I've honestly been thinking about
just getting like a static call graph
thing for these reviews because that
would
help yeah that would
help I mean just because I'm like too
lazy to like either get cold code
folding in Vim or use an IDE that has it
so yeah I basically only see one screen
worth of
stuff yeah it if anything else the
ability to just jump right to a
function's definition is like I can do
that I do that pretty easily oh good
okay
see I just haveck
find can you do it for dependencies
though because I can just do that for
box to internal
stuff uh no I guess I'm not usually
doing that much though um but when I'm
looking for a defa I just type like you
know void like weap and it's just start
typing and it's done yeah okay or in
Python you just look for death
name I don't even have that set up to be
I you can do that across multiple files
I just don't
and you can actually set it up to go to
definition I'm pretty sure you might you
might need an LSP or something but you
can totally set that up I just
so yeah uh a little bit of context on
this you can I think I mentioned
yesterday but you can ask Box 2
positions of bodies whenever you want
but they have a way to get uh
all so they he kind of optimizes it so
you have a list of events like okay
these are all the things that actually
moved in the last step because maybe not
everything moved like a lot of the
floating walls are stationary a lot of
the time so it's nice because then
instead of having to update position of
everything every step or every frame you
can just okay tell me the things that
actually moved and then I'll update the
velocity and the position and yada yada
so that's kind of nice It sped up things
a little bit they have a change
okay that's
fine and yeah I do that bounds checking
here if somehow the stuff is out of
bounds then I'll just destroy it or kill
what is this
so is no uh yes projectile contacts
that's another oh my gosh fairly trick
like involved
all the other projectiles bounce off
each
other that's crazy so yeah basically
that's probably why stuff is slow I
wouldn't be
surprised maybe have a million
projectiles that all have to do contact
checks yeah it adds a lot of interesting
gameplay though like allowing that
because um one counter to the sniper
like you can be across the whole map
from me and try and snipe me but if I
have say the shotgun that's not going to
reach you but I can deflect the snip
spam it
okay stuff like that or if you are yeah
it it adds a lot of cool gameplay
elements and like I said yesterday
projectiles do have the a little bit
more expensive or the more expensive CC
CD stuff enabled to make sure they
actually you know the Collision checks
for drones are accurate but they don't
do the expensive CCD checks against each
other so they can tunnel through each
other but that's not a huge deal phasing
like if a if a projectile was supposed
to hit another projectile but phases
through it that's much less of a deal
than if you try to shoot a player and
then it just phased through the player
so it's a good compromise
this much must might be the first thing
I don't actually
like that you didn't just have uh you
just didn't Define a weapon type zero is
null oh yeah if you forget the plus one
you're screwed yeah I know that's a fair
criticism I know cuz I have there's this
really obnoxious flat indexing over all
the items in neural MMO and it causes a
ton of
I'm surprised that this isn't as easy is
just like adding this to the shape def
of the um the original
body a
joint yeah well if it's rigid like it
doesn't move so I why do you need I I
don't know why it's a joint instead of
just adding it to the shape def out
there of the original body that it's
stuck
to um so that is one implementation but
the way I have things set up I'm kind of
assuming that different entities have
separate bodies so I could just destroy
the so basically this happens I hit the
mine hits a wall and I'm attaching it to
the wall so I could destroy the
projectiles shape and just create a new
shape on the wall um but can't attach
thing okay yeah I I just like to have it
everything always have its own body it's
just e keep track that's fine I I
remember being like it's weird that
there are multiple
anyways so
yeah that function is respond support I
was talking about just making sure
projectiles don't slow
and oh jeez
okay how is this
not hm
handle contact events
okay so yeah some of that's some of that
is kind of Bor boiler py I'll give you
that
yeah okay I just did a test if I disable
continuous Collision detection CCD
across the board it basically has the
run time h
of The Benchmark so yeah CCD is the
biggest offender here and um that's a
off the Gast box Tod Dev about that I
don't really know what I can do about
that myself unfortunately yeah because
uh was it 170k or something in that
Benchmark
yeah oh wait um actually that's not
right I The Benchmark failed
because yeah it hit a bug but um I'm
finding other bugs that I thought I
handled but um things are going out of
bounds all the time now that I have CCD
disabled so that's good
oh never
mind that really didn't affect time that
much I wonder if if you disable CCD at
the World level it still enables it for
I don't know that's interesting it
didn't really affect the Benchmark at
all that seems
what's the distance thing on a
projectile oh so so to what just
distance that's travel since it's
spawned so oh okay I see so it's yeah
okay I see yeah the flat can is the one
that will explode if it's in the
vicinity of a player but I it waits a
distance to do that so that way it just
doesn't blow up in your face yep
whenever you shoot
it and it just adds a little bit of
strategy to it because you can't just
it's really useful at like once you're
it really enforces uh like proper
positioning because if you're too close
to them it doesn't really do
much so kind interesting
this is the end of it here with the
censor
events oh nice
yeah and that's just kind of boiler
plate calling a stuff you already saw
and find your walls is Tiny so yeah
you're pretty much at the
end I wish I had better feedback for you
because it's like all the criticisms
aren't criticisms of your
code I'm honestly starting to see more
what you mean though because
um about the criticisms of the Callback
stuff because uh I'm just why you're
doing this just looking at fixing a
couple other bugs I know of and to a
better I don't know check on something I
might have to write another call back
and I'm just thinking yeah I I shouldn't
really need to write a call back for
this so I kind of understand what you're
saying well it's just like don't take
control Flow Away from the user as
simple as that yeah I think if you use
an iterator pattern which you can do and
see it's you don't need to even use a
freaking iterator pattern like I mean
your Loop is usually going to
be like four like four thing in Loop do
function no but I think it's important
to have some kind of way to stop early
because the advantage of a callback or
iterator over just a dumb Loop is a dumb
Loop um it in it makes it or what's word
for if you just have a dumb Loop box
juty has to gather everything up front
which can be expensive but if you have
an iterator call back it it allows box
Studio to only deliver or find or
provide one thing at a time you iterate
through elements right and then you're
going to have box stud is going to do
things like you know check Collision up
update move like update position right
check
Collision if you just give me the like
the update
position function if you give me the
check collisions function right then I
can write the loop and I can do those
things yeah but sometimes you want to do
checks like for example the thing I'm
thinking about when I'm placing sudden
death walls um right now I just do a
course check it's two course basically
to see if any placed sudden death walls
overlap with um loading walls and the
way I do it is just do they s share the
same tile and there are cases when the
floating wall is touching a sudden death
wall but it's not quite in the same tile
so it just looks weird because they
don't
despawn um so I need to do like a
bounding box check and I need call back
to do that because of box Tod but um if
your box Tod implemented it say bounding
strs the ways you're you you're saying
um I just placed these walls after the
world has stepped so this wouldn't have
gotten caught in like the you know when
you're doing the world step so if it
just worked like okay um I'm going to
provide box 2D with this bounding box
return all the objects in that and then
do what you want with them that's way
inefficient because you could only need
one of them and it could return 100
versus like an iterator call back it
returns or like you know think of a
generator in Python same idea it's
returning one thing at a time and then
if if ever you want it to stop you just
tell it stop and it keeps doing what
it's doing saves you
time so I think the iterator would be
cleaner because then you're still giving
control flow back to the calling code
because it drives the iteration versus
call back where it's deciding when to
call your call back well this would at
least be better you wouldn't even need
the call back then with the yeah exactly
but you'd have an iterator instead I
mean and you could do that and that's
like 10 lines of code to make an
iterator um if you want I to ask him I
highly doubt he would whole like change
the API but I wonder if it just comes
down to yeah I I don't think it's like
one suggestion right I think it is a
matter of like looking at the Box 2D
source and looking at how they do things
first and then like seeing if I'm right
that it's like yeah you can actually
make everything way simpler it depends
how much stuff is happening like when
you do the world step Loop right it
depends how much stuff is happening in
there yeah there's a lot that goes on in
World step I haven't looked I just know
it's a decent bit
but you're free to look at it for
sure yeah I'm curious I I I bet the call
backs just came down to personal
preference or maybe that's just what
he's familiar with but I don't know
there's probably some pros and cons to
doing
yeah it's probably that's probably it
but yeah industry is of course famous
for having good
code yeah I mean to be fair box Tod's
code is pretty good you can't it's not
horrible it's it's pretty
good
um yeah I know I am kind of curious if
there would be a major downside with
iterators yeah not sure I don't know
know I mean I I doubt they're going to
change their whole API though highly
doubt be nice
though anyway um I think I'm I'm going
to grab some water quick and then are
you still good to jump I think we just
we take a few minutes to
mentally yeah and then I think we I mean
we have fun stuff to do now is the cool
thing with the renderer if there's
nothing I like I guess there
is there's like some helpers and stuff
but the main chunk of it is the renderer
now yeah there's some code in the map
file that like pre-computes some stuff
and you can take a look at that
eventually but it's pretty
uninteresting um most most of the map is
just like the map file is just the
layouts of the maps themselves so one
second so uh to leth here
leth
uh yeah I we stream all the dev on this
and pretty much the deal is if you put
effort into pring uh an n and it doesn't
have to be remotely as complicated as
this
like this is kind of an extreme example
but like people have done pong right
they've done
breakout um they've done Enduro was
slightly bigger they've done grid World
type things so the re the rule is if you
put effort like effort into making a
useful m not just like you know
generating something with an llm I'm not
going to like go spend an hour reviewing
like a llm code that does like kind of
works but if you actually put effort
into doing a thing then I will review it
with you line by line on stream and
usually I have way more feedback than
this as well um this is kind of a case
where like Captain is just pretty damn
experienced in C and the code is well
written and mostly the problems that we
have are problems with the engine um but
yeah I like other contributors have made
a few M very quickly gotten on boarded
with this stuff and really really done a
good job in RL and like with a project
of this size it's kind of hard to not
learn a lot about how how RL works and
the process of getting something up and
running on
thish all right let's take a few minutes
and then let's go through the render and
we will be able to do all sorts of fun
stuff there cool yeah I just want to say
to who's ever's watching is interested
in this I'm I'm sure Joseph would agree
with this but I'm not going to speak for
him but if anyone you know if anyone
learns something from this I'm you know
really glad I'm always willing to uh I
don't know I just always like to see
people just grow in their programing
experience so if you ever have any
questions about impulse Force
specifically definitely hit me up in the
Discord server or if you want to DM me
whatever but I in general if you you
know want to do this stuff the puffer
Discord is a great place to learn talk
about stuff whatever Jo has built up a
pretty good community so thank you yeah
yeah the goal of the stuff I do is not
like the primary goal isn't educational
right the primary goal is to shove the
field of RL forward as far and as fast
as possible but it just turns out that
like I have a really really heavy
emphasis on just keeping stuff simple
and fast so it actually does make it
very easy to onboard new people um you
do not need an RL background to like
start contributing you just need a
decent programming background that's all
and like the majority of the M's that we
write you know not so much this one
because of box 2D but even like neural
Mo like a first year undergrad who's
taken one systems course can read that
code so it's just loops and conditionals
and such um now whether you can write
the code while keeping it that clean you
know that takes some practice but you
can at least follow what we're
doing okay we'll be back in a few and
then we will go through the renderer uh
we might even like fiddle with some
stuff live there and see if we can make
some big improvements to that all right
be right
oops forgot to
unmute I think we have the first pure
math contribution
here but does this make sense
the growing
term the
denominator I'd have to look at that I
don't think that works but I'm not
sure I think that like underweights
variance
dramatically I'm not sure
[Music]
oo
better this one would take longer to
optimize right
have to see what the Pito curve ends up
looking
like I think it's likely there is
something in there with that
algorithm takes a lot of experiments and
a lot of
doing I'm thinking we might
uh we might go ham on the renderer C's
put in so much work I might have uh I
might decide I want to have some fun and
like a spruce up the renderer a whole
bunch
nonsense
really all right I'm back hello
so yeah if you you probably will have
some criticisms with this
because you're pretty experienced with
rendering and I am
not also what this is a static array man
what isn't isn't this a static
array you have like a million different
static arrays giant
array switch to case statement this is
like case one case
two yeah this thing pretty silly but
yeah I could definitely make those
arrays okay let's start on this
um drone controlled by
human
that yeah so that's defined in M because
mostly the M does that so
I needed it in here
but oh I game for people watching this
is not resizable is it uh no I don't
really know how to do that oh you
modified it so projectile Stone spawn or
oh yeah I forgot we did that that's kind
of
funny let's fix
that where did we do that
[Music]
um like create
projectile or maybe you just need to
rebuild yeah is a debug
demo uh
yeah deadly
signal
what is it something you changed or I
don't
know that's annoying thing with GCC
sometimes it'll to spam deadly signal
signal like that with the addess
sanitizer but with llm with clang it
will just always like immediately exit
so CLP superiority
gang
well I didn't change
know how it works I
guess I don't know
oh there these like
traces huh these like oh yeah that's the
breaking that's where you break that's
funny it's not implemented super well
because if you're going super fast it
just dots from where your positions were
so if you go really fast and break it
looks crappy but yeah that could
definitely
improved you can see the pathfinding it
went all the way around the
imploder these are like
the scripted Bots do stuff at least yeah
they're not they do stuff just
poorly except for aiming they can aim
well but that's about it they can't put
position well or path find well or yeah
or save
themselves
yeah it's pretty non-ri already decent
scripted bot for this game though
MH okay constants
Ray math and
colors and I have to get you some C and
puffer
colors I'm going to be tempted to like
take a crack at like trying to make like
a cool client update for
this I'm tempted to
one give me one sec my cats are wanting
to come in or
something thousand lines of this left to
review other than the utils and other
stuff all right so yeah what were you
thinking about a client
update I might be tempted to make try to
make a big client update for
this go for
it this is pretty darn cool okay
so Trail points so we are modifying
Trail points from the
client yeah um so like I said my goal
was to keep all the rendering code here
and I have to create things like Trail
points or explosion whatever like I have
to kind of create certain things in the
game file but for the most part any
anything that deals with rendering I try
and keep in here so I create the trail
points uh in the game file because I
kind of have to but then I manage them
here I see and then you took these out
of the end so that the end is
Con uh what do you what do you
mean I I just noticed that you have tril
points past it and I thought it was part
of the end okay oh um it's it's
somewhere in the M
yeah so this is scalable isn't
it uh no I'm not sure why I'm this is
scaling yet isn't
it uh well kind of yeah it it like fills
your screen but it doesn't allow the
window yeah okay sorry it's scalable but
it's not resizable
okay but I'm not sure I go to default
with if I
do if I just change
it okay so right now actually what it'll
do it then stretches
yeah it did change it but then stretched
it
again
yeah yeah it ain't
perfect this a lot of this is easy
though this is so much easy to deal with
in
physics um rone
color weapon
abbreviations weapon
[Music]
names aim guide with
oh
yeah yeah it's really the height but the
way I render the projectiles the width
is kind of like how long they are
so I don't know depends on how you look
at
it basically for different weapons like
the sniper
what um the snipers has a really long
aim guide and other weapons have longer
shorter ones so
oh render the timer I see so we're at
200 lines of constants and things that
should be constants so
far
um so this is only 800 lines that's not
bad actually like
750 here we have the
UI yeah there's I don't really do too
much complex stuff or really anything
complex uh there's a text format in prb
so you don't have to ask for T oh really
oh that's
cool there you go I already got some
used Flor render s suggestions at least
code
index oh all so yeah I think I mentioned
yesterday but uh it's just an easy way
you can keep track of drones around
stuff it's kind of like the Drone ID
basically each drone has like unique
index it's it's literally unique
rendering cords like this I'm
confused oh this is for um the
information like uh what team you're
on
okay so yeah this is just assuming you
have up to four players so
yeah I guess if I was doing tons of
Agents I would just display like the
agents on screen or something I don't
know or just not at all you agents on
stream you could do top players in lobby
there are a lot of things you could do
yeah you definitely do yourself and then
maybe like whoever's on screen at once
but that could get tricky because there
could be a lot on screen so I don't know
maybe maybe just
yourself Circle
lines yeah this is annoying that Raab
doesn't have a function to draw a
donut yeah well they do have a ring I
think that's basically a donut did they
yeah I just yeah I use it other
ring there is a draw
ring I didn't know that okay I I could
have sworn that when I looked this
didn't exist this might be new in
5.5 maybe not but
huh
cool and this is the
where is
it spline this is what Spencer needs
what's a spline and it just draws a
curve
right oh okay H maybe I need that um for
the projectile and drone trails that is
some of
the I did obviously clean it up and uh
conform it to my style but that's some
of the code that's like almost direct
ripped from an LM because I had no idea
how to do do that and it's it looks
halfway decent but um they could be
improved so maybe probably be a curve
yeah what you do is you actually do just
have the dots right and like but then
you draw it as a curve and then the dots
disappear one by one so it actually
Fades
reasonably though I don't know if you
could actually
fade yeah that would be tough cuz I
don't think you can fade like the last
bit of the line eily
H
interesting yeah I don't know draw a
line draw a
text line yada
yada you can also load nice fonts
in yeah the default font looks fine but
yeah we could do isn't it crunchy for
this game let me
see honestly don't mind it thing
oh that's actually my bug not your bug
that's right yeah I remembered oh it's
kind of crunchy it's kind of pixel
crunch well I guess because right now
things are kind of angular but if we put
shaders in this is a lot more of like a
smooth game than a crunch game the way
it is at the moment true yeah I think
this one does work better as a smooth
game as well because there's so much
stuff going on that uh it's less
cluttered right when you have what what
smoother font no no no just in general
like the asset design everything is like
Smooth it's not like pixel RV like
crunchy right
okay yeah I guess the original is
definitely not crunchy at all so that
makes sense like neural MMO is like a
pixel crunch right like the current
version is right but then like the older
versions were like very flat
shaded it's like the opposite of doing
like you know the flat shaded low poly
Style
me ah look it literally all that
literally already it except this is
redundant stupid
I think this will be the function that
we fiddle with today just for fun
explosions
mhm I have some ideas
there Circle
V render empty
cell yeah that's that's not it's mostly
used for debugging I play it around with
rendering like a grid but yeah I don't
use it currently it it is useful for
debugging certain things
though I guess I honestly could take a
page out of Naro and render it if you
press a certain button that could be
useful so I don't have to change
something
compile yeah I might do
that I actually had a in the original
scon version I didn't fully Port it over
just cuz like I designed it stupid in
the original cuz I was using scon
um with like mixed python typing um but
I had like a terminal you could just
press Tia and there was a debug
console well I guess that's easy to do
in Python but you can't really do that
and see very EAS it was in scon well
it's just like I could have done it it
was just a pain in the ass and it's like
I've been working on for too long I it's
technically still in there it's just I
don't think it's actually implemented
like yeah
see you can type stuff in
here oh but just nothing
happens
yeah there was like overlay stuff as
well like you could render overlays in
the game so like there was you could
render like everywhere that the agents
have walked for instance that's cool
yeah
I if I fixed the way the renderer was so
I like just cleaned up some logic I'd
probably want to do more on that but so
much to do got to fix RL
first
yeah see render okay I skipped stuff by
accident so render wall render weapon
pickup B2 V to Ray they have different
coordinates
what's that the different coordinate
systems yeah so box 2D um I Center z0 is
the center of the screen but box is also
unique not unique I don't know I guess
some other physics SS do this but it's
kind of weird to me they have an
inverted y- AIS oh jeez so negative yeah
apparently it's somewhat common but it's
a little weird so like negative one is
like higher up than negative or than one
which is interesting but Ray lib so okay
0 the way I did it is the center of the
screen in box 2D Land but in rayb land
zero is the first pixel at the top left
so I have to convert coordinate
transforms are evil yeah that took me a
while and
sucked yeah it took me so long before I
could even just get the most basic thing
rendering and working yeah it's very
quick once you have all the transforms
but the transforms are just
[ __ ] that is C
um oh this is the yeah okay this was
annoying because this is one of the few
things that box 2D doesn't allow you to
just render at an angle so I had to
compute the figure out how to compute
the angle doesn't let you render sorry
um rayb doesn't let you render triangles
then if you do these in the wrong order
it doesn't show up yeah there's like an
outside there's like you have to Define
them in a certain
whatever well it's funny because I never
ran into that problem I saw that but I
just I just did the vertices and the way
I Define them and it just works so I
guess I just Define them in the correct
order so
yeah yeah the respawn guides are really
cool but that was something pulled
straight from the original that was a
really nice touch
there you're doing your own animations
here with this basically
yeah um but yeah without them it was
kind of hard to track like where you
were and it it looks a lot weirder it's
it's kind of amazing have just simple
yeah no I noticed that immediately yeah
the circle getting smaller it's all it
is is it just feels so much better looks
so much better you need to rename this
to what are you aiming
[Music]
at okay
laser touches the near shape oh so you
actually do have to do box 2D stuff here
yeah you do oh yeah a little bit because
um yeah like for instance if you the
sniper like guide will go as as far as
it possibly can so like if I had a
that's going to be weird actually the
way the sniper implemented in both games
right now the original mine is it just
goes Forever Until it hits something so
I don't want it to go through things so
I have to stop it when it hits
something yeah it looks weird if you
don't do that
I don't know if you notice this but this
is the trail you can kind of see when
drones are going
fast and yeah this is code that's kind
of pulled from LM a little
bit so they shoot yeah I saw it
mhm it looks pretty good
yeah yeah there are times if you change
direction very suddenly you can see gaps
in
it so why does that happen the address
sanitizer deadly signal uh it's no s
thing don't worry about it all right
you know I should Pro this is a minor
change but I should probably change the
velocity at which the um triangles come
out when you kill someone be
proportional to uh how hard the Drone
hit the
thing because right now it's just kind
of randomize between like I don't know
five and 15 meters per second or 10 and
15 but I should make it proportional to
how hard you actually hit it when you
died because then it'd be more satis if
you like slam someone into it with a
burst or shotgun or something it goes
think there are all sorts of things we
can do on the graphic stuff to make it
look
good I'm trying to think whether I want
to mess around with
3D you know
maybe well okay once you get through
this
um you should at least look up some
YouTube gameplay footage of the original
because they have a kind of cool well
they have it
3D they do and they have some kind of
cool effects that'd be cool to
emulate if you have Steam on your um
this computer it's tiny and it's free so
you can download it in like a couple
minutes
oh no we're going to see the OverWatch
Play
Time 80 H it's not that bad yeah but I
that I downloaded it pretty recently on
the steam version nice I think I left it
running a few times to be
fair um so it's not all that is it
okay they got snazzy Retro Music cool
the music is nice I do like the music
see
the some of the loot points are a little
janky but overall it's not
bad here's the
trail yeah you have a lot of different
Trail functions don't
you yeah I could probably make a
function because this is pretty similar
to the Drone I don't
know Baner Tex is one of the last things
I added but I like it a
lot just the big like rier who
won you've
died Dark Souls death
screen yeah every time someone dies it
just fills up the whole screen you did
H my favorite thing ever from that was
the that people in like Dark Souls
because Dark Souls 3 was I think 2016
something like that like whatever right
so uh I mean right before that right
like like the uh most popular mod or one
of the most popular mods I think was the
one that just changed the death screen
from you died to thanks
funny than
that's
awesome I didn't know about that that's
hilarious it's
great thanks Obama now this Abomination
that could only exist in Nightmare just
slip my
throat render explosion okay run break
Trails R pieces
all right that's a little aggressive on
the early returns but
okay so one
line yeah I just I always have the
braces is that what you're talking about
no I mean like the fact that you have a
continue when there's literally one line
that you Skip by like doing the early
continue
I'm okay I get
yeah um I a lot of the stuff in this
file seems like it was done like
quicker yeah the rendering was just a
means to an end for the most part so up
until pretty recently
yeah yeah treat your render code nice
you know it's how your whole game looks
mhm oh jeez my main focus was on the
mechanics and stuff though
so cool so let's take a quick look at
this and then let's figure out what we
can do with the
graphics I just want to see what it
looks like in the
original yeah so you'll have to try
cranking all the effects up and you
might hopefully you don't have thatsy
because you will have
it's so
loud oh yeah I remember that yeah go
into settings and you you want to crank
them back down but it's worth cranking
the graphic settings up once just to see
yeah you probably want to turn like
screen shake and vssh effects off
because those are annoying
or you can just keep it on and see what
it looks like I'm just trying to
say wait it's literally this effect is
it literally is CRT
always yeah oh my
God why dude if you're going to do that
at least make it an option holy
hell
yeah I also do looking at it now think
it's funny that they have like uh
buildings their logo you know those that
I don't know doesn't have anything to do
with the game so it's got there's a grid
around you uhuh that's an absolute
that's parallel axed with the floor uh
so you are above the main floor yeah I
like this sort of like border
thing where they have it's funny though
because it it's funny it it almost seems
like it'd be too busy but when you're in
a game I don't really think it is
oh yeah they have a smoke Trail based
off your
weapon which is kind of funny because
it's not you're shooting bullets but
it's BL on these and like the projectile
impacts are they add a lot yeah aren't
they just like little squares or
something oh they're little like
triangles and squares what are oh they
come off them yeah yeah
[Music]
okay it's funny I never noticed those I
don't think those are frozen on switch
version which is what I usually played
sa
bouny floating cube
variants yeah I like the kind of Bloom
borders around the main walls those are
okay like
that yeah and they have like ammo
casings you drop too that's kind of
cool yeah they they spend a lot of time
with graphics for this game
how did they make a scripted bot or
there I'm wondering the same thing
there's is it shares some similarities
of mine but it's definitely better I
mean they probably spent more time on it
but
um actually oh wait exit to the main
menu CU you can control how good the
Bots are if you do a normal
game I mean the projectiles are like the
main flashy thing that you notice I want
to see what their their models are
though is it just like a spear with a
ring around
that you almost can't even really move
with your arrow keys without shooting
much yeah no that's the
point like you're you're incentivized to
use the recoil because you're so slow
otherwise and can you tell a difference
in speed like you actually move faster
and everything like there's more Reco in
my game because I wanted to make it a
little bit
faster yeah it feels like it just feels
it feels very slow normally and like
it's like almost like I don't want to
it's like I almost don't want to even
pay attention to my arrow
keys they are useful though because they
can counteract some of the recoil when
you don't want it yeah that's the main
thing they're useful
for and then also just getting that
little bit extra speed if you're trying
to go somewhere you you move in the same
direction you're shooting so did you see
the ripple effect they just had that's
what I was talking about oh when you die
like the shock
wave is that what you're talking about
yeah yeah you want to do
that they don't do that with explosions
honestly their explosions look very
similar to mine their explosions are
very
lowkey yeah I think it's funny out wait
to countdown where one human player
so I'm going to do this and then we're
going to try to find some stuff
to this
weapon yeah pick up some question mark
weapons CU then you can maybe see some
explosions um yeah if you
can you have yeah if you shoot that you
kind of see an explosion
oh that's
cool oh yeah that one actually has cool
effects the other the other explosions
are just kind of like circles like mine
but yeah that one looks cool self
elimination
lovely the pause is weird oh yeah
literally it's just triangles oh but
they're triangles that flip around in 3D
that's why it looks cool you see it's
kind of like a 2.5d game mhm mhm
yeah I could probably emulate that even
using box I honestly think that this
would look better in um it's like
they're using like the parall ACT stuff
a whole bunch oh that's sweet what's
that what oh the the mirror bar yeah
yeah so any shot you shoot at it will be
reflected straight back I need to
implement that be I was thinking about
that today it would be easy that's one I
honestly I think that we could make
something that's like kind of similar to
the way that this looks but I think we
might even be able to do better than
this really yeah I feel like that take a
lot of ever do better than this well not
all the shaders obviously
but I think that we can definitely do
something here yeah try and get that
question mark weapon up there I want you
to see a normal
explosion
W uhoh he got it
now there's two oh there they
are oh yeah see watch those explosions
oh okay those have smoke never mind
again okay on the switch version that's
what yeah never mind on switch version
they have like no effects what is this
game this is the this is the game that
Captain's envirment is based off of so
we're looking at the rendering to see if
we can get any inspiration for like how
to Jazz it up a little
bit okay yeah so that's funny I've been
using us this witch game as inspiration
but it honestly worked out better
because their effects there are more
basic but they're easier to emulate so
to start at least a good good
oh oh wait what it brings them to me
it's the imploder oh that is
okay now I'm seeing how the stuff you
implement works now he's got
it I actually don't know if it'll hit
you oh I think in this game actually
they don't do wall
checks okay he screwed up
cool so I have some ideas for stuff we
can do on
this and they sell new weapons and stuff
I
guess uh no it's actually just new game
modes and Maps okay cool
so what if we I'm thinking what if we
actually try to do the
3D right we yeah so the the coolest
effect in 3D I think would be how those
walls are kind of like the angles the
angled you know what I'm talking about
like the perspective thing I don't know
how to do that though I think we just go
borrow Spencer's
code maybe yeah
um oh the the only thing is though this
game has a camera and I just don't deal
with the camera I just show the whole
map so I guess I could Implement a
camera but I don't know I actually don't
like their camera yeah I agree I think
it's it's better I think fixed
perspective like we do fixed perspective
on it
MH so
let me think how we can
do well can you do
begin let's pull up Spencer's code as a
reference actually yeah that's a good
idea I just want to see if there's like
that man knows how to
yeah that's such a cool
M also he's like randomly reedly
generated maps and stuff like Puzzles
that's so cool yeah in 1500 lines as
well yeah that's that's pretty pretty
that's right yeah because he does have a
camera whatp Matrix he's doing up there
oh that's probably animation
stuff so where do we render the map
here uh the map is pretty much just draw
wall or render wall or
whatever so just you think render a cube
instead of a square let me see so this
is for oh but this is inside of begin
mode
2D can you is this right here is this
the main this is it right this is the
main yeah so we
can well okay is it where's begin mode
2D oh we don't have begin mode it's just
2D is a default I
think ah so we're good then well yeah go
into his does he do begin drawing does
he just and then enter 3D mode like
immediately know let's see yeah he does
begin
drawing he
calls right
okay wait what why does he end Shader
mode right after he begins drawing I
guess he does the shaders first huh can
we get the camera from here or
no do we need a camera do you not have a
camera
no
well yeah I don't know if we need one
yeah I mean fish perspective there's
there's no camera well you need to know
where it's fix perspective
from oh
okay
um I just figure
out and it's in the
client yeah make
client what are you looking for
specifically make the
client oh yeah create ra
client okay and then we do R client star
the struct is in types or something yeah
everything's in
Ray
client oh it's just Ray client I think
yeah this is one thing in LSP is nice
for because you can just you don't have
to know the types up front you can kind
of just type and it'll give you options
too
camera Al I'm wondering
like when you're going in 3D
mode it how I wonder how like the normal
positions interact with the 3D
positions like if you if I say draw
something at
z0 where is that in 3D world is that
like z z z I don't
know oh wait you don't want to pass the
camera you want to just pass the client
we're going to do it this well the
client's in the M struck so you have it
oh it is
yeah
okay so
is y up I think Y is
up yeah I think
so uh let me
think
X yeah I don't know I never really
worked in 3D before that's weird
o I'm probably going to have to make
another function that converts box 2D
coordinates to 3D coordinates not
really so we
have extend X is this
it times render scale
yeah so render scale is based on the
size of the map so like the bigger the
map is the small I render
color oh okay so it takes a vector three
width height length and then color so
the first Vector 3 is not the size it's
the position oh it is where is that I'm
just using my LSP to read
it is it pause.
X PA that X yeah I'm not yeah so the
position of it is yeah PA that X pause.
Y but yeah I'm not sure what the height
is or how this works I guess we'll see
Height's fixed
projection what does that mean camera
projection
orthographic for instance was it first
person isometric what like different
camera type oh apparently the two types
are perspective or
orthographic yeah one what's that mean
that's first person no or isn't that the
iso camera I think it's that like
parallel lines um was it parallel lines
don't meet at The
Horizon oh no okay new to me it's um
it's like if you're I think it's
simulates a pinhole
camera oh okay I think that's what you
use an isometric I could be wrong it's
been a long time since I've done camera
stuff yeah I've compatible type for
R2 yeah you don't pass a vector
three oh for
v h for v u do yeah for V you
do yeah I usually like like and using
the V variants better but
Tre builds why is it so
big
uh
I don't know um did you change some of
the like uh or like it was on the wrong
monitor oh yeah that would do
it yeah you should comment out the 2D
walls cuz I don't know because then we
can more easily see if we're drawing the
3D walls it's just going to be above
that like common out the draw rectangle
Pro
stuff is where you right above draw Cube
wires
yeah
function
so I'm assuming this is coordinate
[ __ ] yeah I'm honestly I'm thinking
what it is if is the 3D camera is not at
the right place because you just copied
what Spencer was is also
possible yeah let's just start with
something
simple I always set the camera to be all
zeros and see what that gets us yeah we
don't get any
how well we want the game we want it to
be you want to look at that
like X over two or whatever right well
here's what I think you do so use B2 to
RC convert the coordinates the B2
coordinates 0 0 to um rayb coordinates
because that would get you like the dead
center of the
map
um well that' give you Vector two but we
could probably just pick out the X and Y
and then put zero for whatever what is
it it's Vector two yeah um
like Ray
Center
yeah and is it
B2 to rayve I think B2 VC to rvec I
don't know something like this it should
maybe B2 and then you want to make a v
this has to be V two of the
midpoint yeah B2 V zero is
fine so I Center when I draw stuff in 2D
mode no no no it was fine before because
it expects a box 2D Vector box 2D is
zero is it centered on z z yeah
oh okay
for box 2D like physics stuff it made
sense to me at least to have the world
center be at
z00 yeah the target should be the same
position just like lower I
guess yeah
and then up that's like how it's angled
we probably don't want to have any up
right no that up is which Vector is the
up
Vector is like or Z
up well camera up vector rotation over
its axis that's what it says I'm not
really sure what that means to be honest
oh I think you might be using the client
before yeah you got to call the B2
Vector a like later just call it the
bottom of the
function and move the whole camera stuff
to the bottom basically because I
haven't set the the height and stuff yet
it now my PC is broken
what's what's wrong with it
what
interesting that's strange
yeah I'm not sure why it's happening I
this I would just a bug like just run it
under GDB or something and figure out
like what's happening when you get there
to be
honest B2 v20 is just z0 that's all it
is
guess what cuz we're yeah hold on just
do I locals or I
args oh yeah right we're just passing in
E great right
find why is this we do have the client
made but it's not oh wait you're
breaking on line 49 you're breaking in
B2 Vector RC that's why
zero yeah you need to step into that
function and step into BX X the r or
whatever
weird oh you know what I wonder if the
yeah I bet the E render scale isn't set
yet I bet if you print e like yeah
because I never do this stuff yet zero
yeah that causes a he that causes an
overflow though yeah I don't know how
but I
guess ah e client is not
set n was not client is not assigned to
n
yet yeah yeah yeah that makes sense so
yeah I do that later usually we take you
can just set it for now it's not going
to hurt anything I don't get I don't
have access to it from
here have to move
this oh wait hold on a sec go back
yeah yeah that's why you don't have old
see this is where wall is useful and and
where because I'm pretty sure B2 VOR RAC
expects you to pass in an m not a client
but you don't have all the warnings and
errors as warnings on so it didn't tell
you that you passing the wrong type wait
what yeah you pass in the wrong type
that's why why the [ __ ] does that
compile I
see C that's why you have to enable
warnings as errors because if you don't
see we'll just let you do anything I
don't have all those flags on and I
don't do that the [ __ ] yeah no this is
just I don't have those flags on and I
don't get that type thing that's weird
this is just a product of c being like
40 years old it just it just is that
should not
comp I agree but that's how it
be we don't have M
though yeah so move
this where is this getting called
um the main like like demo or something
calls that
usually demo by yeah or demo what is
this
called see I think it's you're probably
just better off moving this code to be
in demo because um when you call when I
call create Ray client I usually don't
have the demo I don't have the m created
yet so you're better off just you have
it right here
no uh it's not initialized yet
though yeah so just just move this is
going to be hacky but we can work around
it later just move the camera code like
into demo do uh
C that code
yeah we're just trying to get something
working
yeah and change m to be
then I don't know wait
begin did you begin camera 3D or
something uh I think well begin 3D
requires a camera so I I don't know
maybe we're missing
something we're not using
lurp it's just funny when I say
that begin mode
3D yeah we do
that
um begin blend mode blend Alpha that's
the default I wonder why he does that
explicitly
yeah well we should just look it up like
which
access axis in Raab is up and which is I
think that that's you set it with up we
set xaxis up didn't we I don't
vector rotation towards Target but we
don't want any rotation
no do
we This Is How They just set up a basic
scene yeah but for our we want to be
looking straight down so we don't want
any rotation wait camera is at 10 and
10 I okay the first one is X this is
up then Z
is this not just a position and Target
just to be
zero
uh I don't know
H basic scene set up is p the ass I know
well maybe we have you have Y and Z
mixed
up okay I'll try that for
though no well I I was saying
try oh yeah okay okay you're
right that's weird though but
okay so wait change the Y in position to
be like a 100 and then that should be
smaller because we're higher up I just
want to see if that's
yep it's funny cuz you know the stream
is like a couple seconds behind you're
just like oh it works and then I have to
wait for
it cool
okay so so yeah where are our
cues oh right I think you're just all
running them a z z or something you're
all running the same place yeah
I don't think this oh wait no it might
actually I think now we have the
coordinates mixed up right yeah let me
think well when you did z00 that
rendered in the center of the screen
right y so that means we should be able
to use the same coordinates as box CD we
shouldn't even need a transform
them well
yeah which is
nice except their [ __ ] aess is
flipped yeah I mean that's not hard to
just do I can write a function to just
do that but okay why does that happen
what the the deadly signal oh that's my
OS being stupid yeah but what caus it to
do that it's some weird permissioning
error I don't know weird it's
stupid so so this doesn't work the
problem
here
um what's their coordinate system is it
massive or something well yeah may maybe
the camera is too close and it can't see
it
okay that's the only thing I could think
of wait what's the second Vector oh
that's its
size yeah we could see it before it
should be fine yeah maybe Zoom the
camera back out change the camera in
like demo to be like a 100 or something
thing again and then they should be tiny
but we should see
them yeah I think 10 is way too
close don't see
anything I think we just need to figure
out what the cords are there yeah
because it worked at zero so well okay
let's let's just try
changing uh slowly changing yeah render
it one at like you know X is one y is z
z is zero and and then one at X is zero
Y is one Z is I don't know iteratively
do that till we can figure out what
controls what
okay how about this we render another
one at z00 and we color it different so
we can get a better sense of where it is
in relation
to yeah like red or blue or something we
just do like
this oh yeah if we C them differently we
can render a bunch at once and tell yeah
good
idea e
okay where's my white uh I guess white
was first we probably need to draw white
glass because they cover
it it's got to be underneath right I
mean I would assume
so this is
up why is
up what do you mean up why is red to the
left
the axes are [ __ ] up
somehow I think the camera is like
rotated weird yeah I think that that
rotation may
be okay yeah x x should be and if you
change x x to be negative one just
sanity check it should go on the
right we
can just try one thing make sure this
actually still doesn't show up with all
of these
oh here we go oh what' you do I missed
it um I just changed the camera initial
position
okay it seems weird for just going
through
it I love deadly
signal me too my favorite
fav type of signal
so we only see these we don't see the
rest of them I want to see what the
cords are looking like like what's the
scale and
normally well these are massive
is this the is pause the box to De cord
it isn't right uh where's pause def find
no pause is the Raab cord how where do
you get the get wall wall um pause is
the Box you coordinates let's try
that yeah I didn't realize that it was
already
converted it's better is it just like a
one scale thing h
is it like scale is like one unit for
Breck uh I think it's more complicated
than that I don't really remember no
it's wall do wall pause that's not going
to
work so it's wall and and there's a
pause member but they're all uh so
between wall and pause it's a pointer
yeah I I hate how C has different
notation for pointers and
members is so stupid doesn't bother me
it's just annoying to have to do it it's
it's very minor
criticism so how wide are your
bricks um four units by four units is
that they're four units
each yeah like in so the Drone has a
radius of one for reference and the Bri
the um the walls are like four 4x4
signal why are they oh they're moving
cuz oh my
God we're playing we're having fun
reviewed several thousand lines of code
I think I get to have a little fun no
it's super cool like definitely one of
the most able m in my
opinion thank you I will take zero
credit for
that I didn't write it yeah no hey wait
what do you change I just zoomed out oh
very
nice this is bizarre
though it's like they're playing inside
of a
hologram you'll get there no I know it's
just it's just weird looking now where's
the color on
color okay yeah might as well remove the
other ones right all the dra the cubes
you drew that we're trying to figure
you like it yeah this is a good start
the thing I'm thinking of
though I don't think Cube wires is the
like obviously yeah we're gonna do way
more than this obviously yeah but I
don't think you should be able to see
through them all the way yeah we can
because you can't the original we can
totally mess with yeah we can play it
yeah overall I think it is going to look
good so we need to we need to figure out
the camera angle though cuz it's angled
and we want it just be straight up and
down right ah slight angle might be good
it's just too much well if you think
about it if it's if it's looking
straight down at the middle the walls
and the edges are still going to be like
look kind of angled because of the
perspective I think well that's easy to
find to very easy so I don't think you
need the camera to
angle uh I we'll have to play with it
like let's get the scene con constucted
CU it's actually really hard to figure
out what way the camera's looking at
until there's more in the scene yeah
fair
enough wck
is it just pickup pause so you can just
change wall for
pickup and then how big are
these uh pick up
thickness I forget what that
is it's right up there there's um and
that a couple lines above I don't know
what line but a couple lines above
there's the pickup thick no no like can
you turn on lines for my sake CU that
make it a lot easier to help was it
disgusting how do people code this
way interesting result the scene
IW it's using could be RL abused because
80% I was using 80% cars you need to
drive straight just max
speed you can steer a little bit
okay yeah just pick another
scen is making
progress
yes um thickness
somewhere yeah um line 484
and 41 there's a couple different places
yeah but this is a time per
complete oh times the render scale
actually is
correct it's not supposed to be in
pixels no but I I um the render scale is
scaling it based on the the um size of
the
map but I guess in 3D mode I can just
change that to be like the height of the
camera let's see what this is to color
color here actually no remove the times
render scale because we're not doing
that the other wall so it's going to
look
weird but for 2D sense but for 3D I
think I can just get away with right
like making the just move the camera
yeah but I wasn't doing that
so didn't have and in retrospect I guess
even for 2ti using a camera might have
simplified Rec
code though they are a little annoying
sometimes as well it's not perfectly
easy so w is
origin
lime start sneaking puffer colors into
this
thing as long as they look decent for
m i mean it's like a slight sh
this is day two of code
review
yeah oh wait this is yeah you yeah you I
couldn't see it because of the line
numers oh my
gosh okay
coder
that picks interesting
wait so you're actually trying to make
it like 3D 3D why not well render 3D
it's still going to be 2D under
the thing oh so like you're talking like
an isometric we're just making a
client yeah and we're not going to have
that camera angle we're just figuring
out how to do 3D in rib yeah cam camera
is definitely a uh final boss in my
opinion I honestly really wonder what
would happen because I've been kind of
hesitant to like I give credit you know
to original
devs uh like in my read me of my guy or
whatever but I'd be really curious to
know like what would happen if they
actually knew about it like I doubt they
would like try and like take it down or
something would they like it would they
try and be like Oh infringement like I
don't know it depends I don't think that
there's enough that you
can you don't think fair use for
research well it's being used for
research it's like what there no assets
you can patent here because it's like a
perfectly
plain mhm right render can't patent game
mechanics it's not being you can but
they didn't you can't really there
literally been one one case that I know
of which is the dumb Nemesis system that
they got for fors and that was like a
fluke yeah I'm just saying it is
possible but yeah they obviously
didn't um oh here's your dra Circle
perfect
three right
pause fa pause drone pause X
yeah we don't want the raiload paws I
guess radius man radius uh it's just
one this just one yeah drone radius is
just one but that's you know that works
too gotta love that cheat
sheet yeah I that definitely works works
I just either Google stuff look at
examples or my LSP honestly is like
usually good enough because it kind of
like you know you can hover over
something and just tell what the uh the
comments are on it what the parameters
are blah blah blah so it's nice because
then you don't have to have another
thing open maybe I will get an LSP but I
I feel like it's a crutch you
know I mean I could code without it I'd
just be
slower I'm only very marginally slower I
miss having follows okay occasionally or
something that's about it
yeah I mean I don't know it's it's
definitely preference like you can go
without it like your proof of that I
mean the thing is I have super Maven so
it's like it's kind of soft fuzzy LSP
anyways well a lot of the main features
I like I'm not like error checking or
whatever is like nice but a lot of the
main stuff um I use like you don't have
so I don't know I I don't have the
structure in the code to like
well it's not like I've never used an
LSP are you kidding me okay I was gonna
say no I've used all I've Cod man I've
coded was it net beans uh we've got like
Eclipse I've coded in freaking VSS code
for a year that garbage uh I've done
stuff in Sublime I've done all sorts of
dumb stuff okay you ever use Adam back
in the day I tried it briefly but then I
decided I only liked it for HTML and
then I I decided I'm just going to edit
my HTML and B yeah e just can't imagine
personally using again I get why you
don't like some of them but just using
something with some of the Creature
Comforts and being like nah I don't know
yeah because like I the thing is you use
them right and they're like you know
they're kind of heavy they're kind of
slow and then like I use this for like a
couple days I'm like well I'm just as
comfortable here as there actually it
doesn't get in my way as much and it's
portable and I don't have to do yeah I'm
just going to do
this fair enough I would just be really
annoyed without a lot of those features
H I just got annoyed at the editor yeah
fair
enough you can edit [ __ ] and whatever it
doesn't freaking matter but oh no it
doesn't I don't know I value the thing
being like super fast and super portable
and like I have my editor in the
container which is great no that is cool
and I will say I hate how V code is
electron and everything else is electron
and garbage and all that
so the TRS are like oh they look naked
so things are onong well be it's because
the 2D like thrusters and movement and
stuff are rendering but they're not
synced up to where the Drone like spher
are so it looks weird yeah work in
progress is the yeah drone radius okay
bullets I'm wondering how I'm going to
render if we do decide to fully inv 3D
I'm going to render the energy meter
because that would be weird in 3D
probably just like a 2d thing on top of
the sphere do that yeah
but I'd like to kind of map it so it
folds around the spear
maybe I don't know it's GNA be funny
because I do think it's really clean I
do think it's really clean and
minimalist how the meter is right on the
Drone itself so you always know where to
look for it but I don't know how I'm
going to do that in
3D they don't have to do
that yeah even I I kind of got the
inspiration of of that meter from breath
of wild and breath of wild it's a 3D
game but the stamina meter is just 2D so
CU it's
UI I don't
know I do not like the way this
parentheses is closed
oh yeah in other languages incredibly
nitpicky on everything see this would be
what I would if you got this reviewed
next week this would be everything it's
like why the hell is this parentheses
not closed like
this wait what are you what are you
talking about
parenthesis oh like how it's closed here
on like a many line instead of on the
new line oh I didn't realize you could
do that because I kept trying to have
cuz normally in most languages I have a
trailing um AMA like after drone color
and it won't wouldn't let me do that so
I thought I had to do what I did I
prefer what you
did I didn't realize you could do that
so that's nice I didn't know
that or else I would have just do it on
one
line
yeah it just looks a little cleaner to
me I probably should not review anyone's
code next week I will be in a very
shitty
mood [ __ ] second rot Canal
[ __ ] so yeah do you have to go back
and get some is it like a followup for
the first root canal no it's that the I
had two teeth drilled by stupid dentist
who like screwed it up and like they
should have just told me to get them
both taken out cuz they're wisdom teeth
anyways but they told me to get a root
canal on one and then they screwed up
the second one so now I have to go back
for a second like I absolutely would
have just gotten them out but this is
ridiculous yeah I know some people who
have had similar things happen like they
screwed up a root canal and yeah it's
they no they didn't screw up the root
canal the dentist who drilled the tooth
screwed it
up ridiculous something like my number
one reason to avoid dentist
stuff don't want to have it messed up
and be a
constant I mean you need healthy teeth
but you also need good dentists to know
what they're doing well that's the main
thing is I just like I like I take care
of my teeth but I didn't get to the
dentist like regularly at all over the
course of my PhD because I like I never
really got doctors in
Boston yeah still I don't know wisdom
teeth it's a
little
sus so you never had your wisdom teeth
removed then no I why would I have room
for
them use them to eat thank you very much
yeah I some people like I got them out a
little later than most but I think they
were saying like they're going to get
impacted or something like they were
going to push some normal teeth out yeah
but if I think for some people to get
you to do the surgery yeah I don't know
that may be true that may where's the
coordinate in um in box 2D space
here
uh yeah should be peace pause and then
V1 oh okay it is literally just V okay
that's super easy yeah yeah
and then this is draw was it triangle
strip a triangle strip I don't know what
that is oh it's a 2d thing though well
triangle
3D draw triangle strip I don't know the
difference
do
it it's
probably it's probably just like the
wire thing you have to define the
points yeah I think I might go in a few
minutes though
um uh it is really nice outside where
I'm at and I think I might just enjoy
fair enough yeah touch grass I've
already I already went for my run this
morning nice
yeah it's back day
[Music]
today nice every day is back day when
you have to freaking
carry fair enough carrying an entire
field of AI in your
back is it piece
pause is it
V2 oh it's just
V2 V1 yeah you probably want to use the
the v v stuff instead of because it's
it's rotated
correctly why you raising them up a
little bit on the
floor what I do what I
do color
color
um um
um
yeah
boom you see that mhm it freaking it
works wait I I missed the death thing
what yeah where did they
die
yeah here watch
this it actually does it in here oh nice
wait that was weird it was way far it
was kind of far from where you died
I it was over here this was the yellow
one dying okay you can't tell because
the freaking things are rendered weird
yeah
bullets where the
bullets they're just circles with
Trails where what's the function called
uh projectile render projectile
triangles yeah that's what CH do yeah
okay here's the below it is the
projectile and then draw a
circle yeah very very simple
work probably don't want to do render
scale times radius
because it's a little bit
big a little bit perfect a little
bit like blowing balls I love how easy
this rendering [ __ ] is with now look at
this look at
this you already have the freaking
projectiles like yeah it's been half an
hour since we got the uh like the first
3D thing
working it's definitely easier than some
other I'm have fun with this tonight I
literally haven't gotten to code
anything that's remotely enjoyable to
code in weeks
so next time I have trouble Joseph I I
know who I'm going to bother with with
uh with visual I don't want to look at
your damn code no your code's gotten
better your code's gotten way
better thanks
bro it's littery just don't overthink
things simple thoughts don't think got
it think simple
thoughts me like Loop and if me like
Loop and if all right me not like Fancy
clever thing that's not really that
clever
make everything a float got it floating
in pretty much I don't use very I don't
really use other types unless there's a
damn good
reason yeah valid he doesn't even like
switch cases or switch statements either
[ __ ] so much unless you unless you
actually know that you need that jump c
table don't do that well for me it makes
maintain maintainability easier for
example like like okay I'm processing
entities or processing weapon types or
something and then it makes it really
easy for me to add a weapon because I
don't need to add an if statment I just
need to add a case it's if type equal
weapon War but I don't I don't
understand why you don't like switch
statements because of the fall through
he doesn't like how they look he doesn't
like fall through is useful though
sometimes aesthetically they annoying to
it's a great source of bugs look maybe
it's because I was introduced to them
was a brand new Pro and like fall
through is horrible but I also just
don't see the point to be fair though I
don't like how C does switch statements
because in go breaks are implicit and um
which makes sense to me and fall
throughs have to be explicit okay then I
be happier that makes more sense yeah I
would be Happ because there's a fall
through well actually I think there
might be a fall through keyword in C but
it's like use I mean it's useless it's
just I guess for clarity you can do it
um but in go you have to say fall
through when you want to fall through
but you don't have to break I keep I
keep running into I forget to break
because in go you don't have to break
out of a case it's just done because
that's sane but you have to explicitly
break at the end of a case statement and
C which doesn't make sense to me well
you have to do everything kind of
explicitly that's the point right I mean
yeah but I don't know I just think they
should have swapped around the
implicitness and explicitness of fall
through and break it makes more sense
but probably a hindsight thing well
bring it bring
it meeting they're not going to change
that it breaks so much code
LOL this is it
wrong
some well I see The Brak Trail but I
don't see like the Drone Trail
yeah oh I'm looking at the wrong place
hold on no I I agree it's not showing
the Drone Trail I don't see it either
it's
we need to fix this perspective is
looking pretty good but perspective
throwing me
what's up with a deadly signal
anyway it's a signal that's
deadly all right humor me let's just try
to change the angle to zero I want to
see what that looks
like because that's probably what we end
up wanting I think you'll want a very
slight
angle H I don't know personally I think
it'll look weird if going straight up
we'll see
disappeared looks good make it an angle
of
radian
okay yeah that looks pretty good to me
because the you can see the angles on
this that's very very interesting
perspective barrel and stuff in the
circles if you're going to go I'm going
to probably still work on this for like
another hour or half hour before dinner
and like keep fiddling with
stuff Barrel this looks so good though
the three like this is going to be
awesome why are the circles so blocky
there's supposed to be Spears aren't
they they look yeah I just have to
fiddle with that no wor no but I all you
did was draw a sphere they shouldn't
look like that I drew a wire mesh
spere okay with like not enough
divisions I that'll get he's got he's
got six divisions so it's you want
everything into 3D first before you
start fiddling too much no I know I just
I just was wondering if that was like
their default look or something yeah but
it's good progress for
sure like the bounces are like awesome
that that actually just works in
3D is there
Aion is there a top to this where did
where did the green one just or the one
yellow one just went off the top oh yeah
it's it's not like centered correctly or
we Pro the zoom out oh yeah that's
because yeah just zoom it out a little
bit eventually right yeah the maps are
different sizes so needs to be variable
Zoom then yeah I handled it different
Zoom or whatever yeah well that's an
easy
fix famous last words no that
is I I envy your
skills you'll get there if you said just
spend more time it's just an like just
time thing really just a quick quick
little 10 years time this is definitely
a Time on time on task oh dang I guess I
have been programming for 10 years
almost I just want I've been programming
at this point I'm pretty sure for more
than half my
life I've I've been programming since
2016 16 so not even 10 Years yet I guess
that's pretty damn good
progress yeah about I think 14 years for
me I've been a decent there's been
decent points in my life though where
getting better at program was like my
sole Focus though
so not necessarily like doing leak code
and crap just like working on Ambi PR
sure that makes you a worse
programmer what Le code yeah I do not
I'm not a Le code enjoyer no me neither
more just like grinding on projects I
found interesting that's exactly what I
do yeah I I'm pretty sure I would fail
like an entry level leode
screen Cod can't be pass like entry
level but the funny thing is I could
have passed one at least when I was like
18 so 10 years ago I could have passed
one and I mean we could study for
it but I won't because like screw that I
know I don't want no stinking
shop we Cod puffer all
day all right so before I dip for a bit
though um we're making good progress on
this but big picture besides you know 3D
ifying everything um else some better
effects and stuff as well yeah like what
do you want to do in that
front um I I'm just going to play with
some effects and then
I think we're gonna probably end up
wanting some shaders or at least like
some basic stuff and it's going to be
hard to tell until we see it but I think
that we can do something closer to that
actual game and maybe even a little
better we'll see oh one thing I I did
want to ask you about
so yeah I think I I think I showed you
yesterday the like the um po shot burst
shot mechanic
right yeah
so I H I haven't decided what I want to
do but I want to add some indication if
a player does that because sometimes
it's hard to tell like with weapons by
the sniper they go so fast it's hard to
tell if you pulled it off or not yeah so
but I it's not it wouldn't be added if
anyone deflects a projectile with a
burst it would only be if you shoot and
then immediately burst it it would like
look different to tell you like yes
congratulations P like a
semi-transparent for like solid green
sphere around it or something
make like a spear around the projectile
yeah I don't know that that sounds like
it kind of look weird I don't know I'll
try I'll try some stuff yeah but yeah I
don't know yeah cool but yeah that's
just that's just something I wanted to I
didn't know what I wanted but I wanted
some kind of effect because it's kind of
a semi difficult technique to pull off
but I wanted to give you some visual
feedback that you did
it also for
uh for what oh yeah for
that I don't know if you actually want a
cylinder you probably might just want to
keep that 2D just add some like sh like
uh shaders on it or something but you
can try it at this point nothing nothing
you you can say will convince it to not
throw the
cylinder well if it if it looking bad
will convince me not
feel all right let's see if this thing's
smart enough to at least fill in the
basic ass arguments apparently
not to be fair this is not a good like
this is not a good code model it's just
a really fast code
model this is this is something that
llms cannot do by the way they should be
able to if I roted it should be able to
a but they can't at all like really hard
it would just Google it would just
Google all these functions and then it
would know the signatures but it it it
well it doesn't even need to it
literally has has the definition so it
would just never get it would never get
the signatures wrong because you just
like do these things not have an LSP
integrated with the llm like how the
hell have uh have like open Ai and
people not done this by now right just
integrate in L an LSP with the llf done
I wonder if co-pilot does that I don't
know I haven't played with it if it gets
signatures wrong then it doesn't yeah
I've never used it you don't use any do
not use any form of code complete no I
do I use I I should probably try other
ones but this one's worked fine I use
like Cody by Source graph all right yeah
I use super map and it's just you get
one of them and it's just as a typing
buff it's just a typing buff honestly if
you type 140 wpm you don't need it but I
don't so same no I use something similar
it's just yeah like line complete with
an LM I use something similar um yep and
in fact I wish I could disable like when
it tries to complete like a whole thing
I wish I disable that cuz I never wanted
to do that yeah there is probably an
option for that
probably you can you can you can use
super Maven too by the way they're on
the the puffer
boxes if you want to
try yeah cool
well I might because I already have
started on that I might today or
tomorrow or something finish probably
tomorrow finish the black hole weapon
because that'd be really cool to have
yeah um and then I don't know sync up
with you and maybe start trying to
figure out some of the 3D stuff probably
hit up Spencer too or do I need to write
sweeps H are sweeps
done what are are what sweeps done are
any sweeps done for this have you
implemented day sleep Logic for it not
INF Wars yet no okay well it's not
integrated with puffer not yet not yet
yeah it will
be yeah I got to do a little bit more
and then get the figure out the build
situation with box but I don't think
it'll be bad like I said I think I'm
just going to create well yeah I think
I'm just going to create um a get Hub
actions on the puffer box Tod Fork that
just Builds an archive whenever we push
a commit um and then we can just yeah
whenever we want to pull from upstream
or modify something it'll just already
have something ready so that'd be
good yeah I'm enjoying
rendering I'm glad you do because
honestly rendering is like my least
favorite part n dude this stuff's rocks
all
right I don't works I don't know why I
hate it so much but I don't know it just
shitty rendering libraries for a long
time no I just this is literally the
first rendering thing I've done what you
don't like to have visuals for your
projects I mean it's a means to an end
for me like the the back end stuff is
what really interest
me a new Branch looks like Jason has a
top
tip I Jason makes a bunch of funny
things that I'm like
I don't context but it I don't
know um say oh yeah I don't
know it was satisfying to get rent like
some effects working and stuff but um I
don't know the the mechanics of the game
like making those work is much more
interesting to me like when I'm just
banging my hands the wall like trying to
you know oh this thing isn't rendering
at this place because of the stupid
reason that just really basically just
really annoyed me and fruster me really
quickly when rendering stuff didn't work
it is
rough but versus like I don't know I
could spend like five hours trying to
figure out why some obscure bug like try
toix obscure bugs are the worst I mean I
didn't enjoy them but I had a much more
patience for them versus like oh this
thing won't render correctly I would
just get annoyed and just like yeah I'm
just gonna not do
this so I don't know
but I'm glad there are people who like
the rendering stuff like you and Spencer
I mean like I I like it to point but it
annoys me when it doesn't work that
height I
guess uh the width is like how long it
is the withd is how long it is yeah oh
so then this actually should
it I might have mixed them up I'm not
sure hopefully
not
Ric oh I knows it works in 2D
charge aim guide whip charge aim
guide aim guide
whip oh
yeah oh yeah um yeah yeah makes
sense you got a changer for all three of
them all
three now you have charged aim guide
height
oh yeah I don't have charging G width
because use the same width just
different
height ra
cylinder all right I think I'm gonna go
touch grass but um go touch
grass yeah uh so you're going to keep
working on this for a little bit yeah
I'm G to take like two minutes probably
and then I'm going to see what we can
just crank out on this see if I get
something looking half decent cool the
depending yeah I might pop in when
you're do still doing stuff who knows
yeah I'm going to like do a little bit
more in this then get dinner then be
back and I'm probably just going to keep
coding on this because I'm having fun
cool I'm not going to complain with you
helping yeah I figure I owe you a little
help and I'm like I'm so sick of doing
shitty algorithm Dev I just want to
build some
stuff yeah I mean I think workout this
game is fun so programming games is a
lot more fun than wondering hey when if
Lambda should be
normalized I wonder if Lambda should not
be normalized in this
manner yeah that stuff is interesting to
me but given it's mostly over my head
it's more interesting to kind of watch
what you're doing but yeah I can imagine
figuring that stuff out
is yeah to esoteric I tried it did not
train
unfortunately uh I do have training by
the way I know if we like uh we want to
see fancy
algorithm see you did you did you take
oh look at
that solved in 148 so far on this
sweep
and so far on this sweep and way longer
on this sweep 500 474 on this
sweep both running now do I have a
purito in M whato there is pito in M
well yeah you got to make it
GRS so wait which which sweep was the
fast one which one is slow what was the
difference um right now the uh it's
doing better without any
normalization oh
interesting but the normalization is the
thing that's going to make it work
across different Horizons without you no
no no that's a separate thing uh this is
just a random hack
experiment oh cool so you just you have
to run a lot of cuz there's no like I
got the math right now it'll work it's
like I got the math right and the
environment says [ __ ]
you welcome to reinforcement learning
have a nice day I just can't imagine
doing algorithm Dev for five years of a
PhD well no that too obviously but doing
it at the normal RL speed like the preu
RL speed like okay you're not doing
sweeps like you're you're waiting you're
waiting as long as you're waiting as
long as it takes for us the sweep to
come in to do like one or two runs like
that's insane you just have a bunch of
really overworked and really depressed
grad students that's how it works yeah I
guess it just sucks there's no way
around it yeah I mean even now the
iteration times are really long compared
to other areas of Cs but it's still like
a million times better well literally
thousands of times better faster right
well for welcome to puffer yeah we have
made a difference
here oh I know I it's going to be
exciting when researchers or people like
The Wider what's this RL Community I
guess wider RL Community is so tiny it's
even if people know do really make a
difference but I don't know it'll be
cool when people start actually taking
notice uh I mean we have a few clients
like I don't really care if people take
notice or not as long as like we improve
the science and you know we uh continue
growing the company enough so that it's
like we can keep expanding stuff out
building but I'm just saying like if you
actually create like concrete
improvements like because you're on
track to create like a concrete
Improvement to PO and also you know have
better sweeps like that's really
substantial I would imagine at a certain
point they're going to take notice well
you would think so but a lot of the
times they just bury their head in the
sand and keep running their slow Atari
experiments I mean
if that's what they want to do well it's
because they have compute right what I
no they don't that's the funny part they
literally don't so they just don't sweep
any hyper parameters and they just
publish invalid research yeah brutal
it's literally what they do you can't
make this stuff
up yeah and sweeps are huge like sweeps
can you know not having good hyper
parameters can totally make or break
something so that's just crazy this is
pause X
Throne PA X anyway um I will have I will
you know if you need if you were totally
stuck or something just like add me on
Discord and I'll see it but yeah I'll be
back in a little bit
maybe see you guys see you all right I'm
gonna take two and then I'm GNA come
back and we're gonna finish this stuff
um for folks watching since there are
quite a few of
you all the atp. a it's all the Source
we got demos right here uh if you want
to help us out for free just start the
GitHub it really really helps and if you
want to get involved with Dev you don't
need any prior RL experience just need
to know how to
code discord. GPU links on the website
as well I'll be right back and then
we'll keep going on
hello hicc up to myself in the process
somehow
be a guy
dox oh yeah you totally screwed this up
so this is here this is rone pause X
drone
pause
five see drone pause y perfect
now charged aim guide height charge a
guide yeah this now this is
good um
believe oh here it is aim guide height
aim guide
wi
with
uh did not get any lift over over
previous so
far rectangle
3 not draw a rectangle 3D I tell you
that
draw a cube withth height length width
pause one pause
two color
it's a bit much isn't
it perfect perfect push it oh actually
no it's not it is it's there it's just
there's an extra
thing like
look are those
cylinders uh there's an extra thing I
can't tell
the first thing it it defaults to to do
fix
go uh they look they look funny now yeah
no there's still there's some stuff
through with them I'm just trying to fix
initially what's still in 2D
explosions they look tods yeah
explosions and a couple other small
things around the Drone
explosion
pause explosion death do position
all
off this
is okay
position fall off and in the Drone
color and then same position
radius and explosion color without the
fall off then drone
color there your
spheres then this one here
position fall
off then it does fall off color and then
perfect
tell well they look like they could
be they're just not uh yeah it's
plausible let's just figure out where
else we have 2D stuff and then we'll
start fixing
X is
this these charge meters are all going
to need to be
this doesn't look like this is in
um the right space is it
that let's focus on what we can do
here so first of all
the drones look terrible
there you know actually I might want to
flip
these oops
though that looks like uh looks like you
need glasses
me maybe it's
no try this
shield did you change the block the what
did you did you change the blocks how
they
are perspective I haven't change the
blocks yet okay I feel like they're
weird especially the ones towards the
center so we may as well do while I'm
I'm trying to figure out what this uh
the
colors okay there it is so that's
better some
black should not be there
what happened to the Drone
one oh because they're dead that's
why it's
agree don't get a map that has it but it
looks better on the
oh that one looks a little darker than
the other ones
I don't like the top down I think it
needs to be
yeah but you got you got to fix this
double
vision which double
vision the uh
especially towards the
middle
the environment look blury I think it's
because of the perspective where you've
got the
lines uh that are forming the sides of
it especially
like the red cubes like the one in the
middle you see how it's
doubled but you know you're really it's
just a cube yeah that you're looking
yeah the angle is rough yeah that is uh
but but because they are translucent you
can see all of the we'll leave it then
we'll leave it at top down for now I
like no I like the the 15 degree
though I think the 15 degree looked
good well I mean that's going to be
that's the what the perspective gives
you right okay we have less translucency
on the
cubes yeah we could do it like really
faint
or you know inner cubes
are not translucent the outer ones are
that's nice this is like
subtle let me let me make it like full
full
that's not
it oh because hang
on rail
with is totally
wrong but uh this is better
here there it
is now you see the trail
how you
tell very possibly yes I don't think
they
do doesn't look like it is it looks they
just look like fear they don't look like
uh
they definitely look like Spears yeah
they don't look like they need to have
like Trails for them well they're sort
of maybe I did it
wrong 02 one
right they are sort of trailing like
there is a motion e effect I don't
remember how it was
before wait Trail points Trail
points how does this get uh updated
though ra
okay so this does
work this does at least
run uh the question is just
why don't we see
called ah you commented it
yeah that's
silly
holy well they got Trails on them now I
can see but uh yeah that's a little bit
of a
thats I commented
just just this
Spears oh No there are circles there are
flashing spheres so maybe it is not
uncommented hey sorry if you get these
often I really want to get deeper into
RL oops I can do some basic python but I
want to learn the math better
recommendations for
sources honestly the engineering part is
the hard part
um my so if you want a lot of math like
the Su was it Su Ardo book or uh
spinning up has some or whatever but if
you want like a relatively quick with
like as much math as you need to get
started and to understand
stuff right here I made this for this
exact
chat so uh this Blog has some of my
perspective a couple fundamental terms
and then it also has links it just tells
you what papers as well to read
so read this blog read this paper refer
to this paper read this read
that so on and so
forth It's a pretty short list though
and it'll give you a lot of the context
you're
missing and then hey build some uh build
some M for puffer lib this is how we we
get all the all the contributors around
here you know picking up our out turns
out that uh building a new en and
getting an RL agent working on it from
scratch is a really good way to learn in
addition to a good way to contribute to
the
field it does not have to be remotely as
fancy as this like you can build useful
lends in a few hundred lines of code
insane it's something you just changed
if you render the trail it's somehow oh
you know what it
is it's the uh the Double begin and end
mode 3D it
close I uh I code reviewed it and then I
was like hey why don't we make a 3D
client for
it why don't we just make the client
3D been on this for like a couple hours
now it's not that hard when you have a
2d client to just Port it to
b3d obviously there are a few things
that are still missing and not working
yet but for
I wonder if you can do
that just
might be just hard to get this to run
the way we want it
to it was always a hard Pro problem in
my mind
thank you
Ron honestly like rayb is one of the
best damn projects out there it's just
so
for pry game well yeah it's just py game
is just a sucky
API honestly I like RB in C more than in
Python you can use rib with like
virtually the same API though in Python
it's right there aesthetic void dra Tex
3D well that's just a
wait yeah it's still right there well
it's not part of the library
it's just part of a
demo
really that's fine we can just put
it copy
it that that makes that makes sense
that's definitely in the spirit of the
library you want 3D text you have to
draw your draw it
yourself want
text uh I forgot
position 3D text
LG apparently
no it's it's the it's the warm warming
up of the
weather yeah it's warming up in Florida
what
I'm going to go find myig for this
because this is going to drive me
freaking
crazy debug this
hell okay apparently don't do
that
oh linking error I
see undefined reference
know how I end up with this on the wrong
order that's
go letter
bound oh
there not positioned the way we want it
but there is text
then we do what is
it pick up thickness
that didn't do much did
it oh because you didn't put pause in
jeez position
minus a position minus thickness over
two
read well I mean we're going to get
icons for it
anyways it's probably just small
what else are we
missing okay those initial spawn
right you have all this
stuff doesn't render until you are ready
here
kind of
cool we have to improve on it but
okay now what uh what else is not 3
rified
yet a couple small like ammo counters
and stuff but other than that it's
holy oh that's actually pretty cool yeah
uh I'm trying to think how
I get to zoom out
this yeah that's was it I don't think
the position maybe the position does
something
uh what is the correct value of that in
here
we'll fiddle with that
later I just want to get something and
go get up
food yeah that's sweet
though know that
better obviously there's a ton of stuff
to fix but like yeah know that that's
definitely looking uh there's like Jank
stuff but there's also a lot of cool new
stuff
right yeah no this is this is not
confusing anymore to
my to my eye it looks it it it looks
cool
too
okay
so it's getting late so I got to get
food I may or may not be on after this
let's take a quick look at the
experiments see if we got anything cool
in here
all right puffer are those public can
anyone look at them yeah okay I got a
bookmark your
Neptune up for
AI we'll see how this does it needs to
run more experiments for sure though um
okay and for the folks still
watching all my stuff is free and open
source it's right here puff.
if you want to help out the project for
free please just go ahead and start the
repo it really does help us
out um and other than that if you want
to get involved join the Discord
discord.
GPU or just click the button you can
follow me on X for more RL
content so blog here but then there's
more on the x that you can't find
anywhere
else so thank
you and uh yeah more de tomorrow the